22.06 Uhr fritzt der Sender Chaosradio die Sendung 66 die Nummer. Meine Herren.
Meine Herren.
Guten Abend.
Meine Damen.
Die Zivilität mir gegeben hast, ist ein Haufen Scheiße. Nein, nein, nein.
Die Pausen da drin, das gehört so.
Ja, sicher.
Das ist laut Stockhausen die Gleichberechtigung von Ton und Stille.
Ja sicher. Und jetzt gib mir mal Winter. Nichts schon gut, also ich wollte nur ein bisschen umkommen.
Wir haben uns ja auch schon überlegt, ob wir nicht vielleicht eine Viertelstunde Taliban-Musik spielen. Das wäre dann stille, weil Musik da ja verboten ist.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich komisch. Herzlich willkommen im Chaosradio 66 an den Knöpfen Holger Klein. Das ist mein Name. Ich nenne mich zuerst, weil ich der Esel bin. Außerdem sind noch hier Jan und Thorsten von Indymedia. Wer wissen will, was das ist, schlägt es im Internet nach. www.indymedia.org, mit Y das zweite I quasi als Y. Also ihr wisst schon. Außerdem natürlich Andi Müller-Magun. Das ist der mit den Amseln. Na ja, ist schon ein bisschen eher okay. Und dazu noch Bommi Baumann. Bommi Baumann, vielleicht dem einen oder anderen bekannt, aus den 70ern. Da gab es nämlich schon mal Terror. Zumindest in Westeuropa gab es Terror. Und einer der Beteiligten an diesem Terror in Westeuropa war Bommi Baumann. Ein Gründungsmitglied der Bewegung 2.
Juni war es.
Zweiter. Zweiter. Ja, ich war erster. Ja, die heute im Studio und warum, das kann Andi sagen. Der weiß nämlich das Thema viel besser als alle anderen.
Ja, im Grunde genommen schon. Wir haben uns ein bisschen überlegt, Thema Relativität.
Relativität.
Realität oder auch die Relativität der Realität. In Krisenzeiten, wir sagen, wir machen uns ein bisschen Sorgen, ob wir überhaupt erfahren, was zum Beispiel in Afghanistan wirklich passiert, ob es Afghanistan überhaupt gibt, was die US-Militärs uns da erzählen und was also zwischen diesen ganzen verschiedenen Propagandaschlachten, die sich binladen mit den Amerikanern und wie sie alle heißen, gerade liefern. Das heißt, wir möchten ein bisschen auch über das Thema Gegenöffentlichkeit reden. Die Frage ist natürlich, was ist Öffentlichkeit? Die muss man glaube ich beantworten, bevor man über Gegenöffentlichkeit reden kann. Indymedia ist halt ein so ein Projekt, aber wir möchten sozusagen diese ganze Situation, die wir gerade haben, zum anders nehmen, um mal ein bisschen darüber zu reden, wie wir uns eigentlich die Wirklichkeit vorstellen oder wie wir uns die eigentlich mit Hilfe von Medien bilden und wie realistisch die überhaupt ist.
Chaosradio 66 auf Fritz und ich stelle mir die ganze Zeit die Frage, was macht dieser Terrorist in meinem Studio?
Ich bin ja dafür verantwortlich, ihn angeschleppt zu haben. Ich habe mir halt überlegt, es ist wichtig, wenn wir über Afghanistan und die ganze Ecke da reden, dass wir auch jemanden dabei haben, der so ein bisschen die Kultur, die Mentalität der Leute und all das kennt. Und da ist der Bommi Baumann eben ein ausgewiesener Kenner. Der hat da fast zehn Jahre, glaube ich, gelebt in den 70er Jahren.
Mit Zwischenräumen.
Ja, das musst du jetzt mal kurz erklären. Es war ja irgendwie so, dass du in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland so ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, eingeschränkte Freiheit genossen hättest. Ja, dann musst du mal ganz kurz den Hintergrund, wo du dich aufgehalten hast.
Vielleicht auch erstmal biografische Daten, oder? Weil den meisten dürfte Bommi Baumann kein Begriff mehr sein.
Ja, gut, aber wir machen ja keine Sendung über biografische Daten. Aber eine Sendung mit Bommi Baumann und den erklären wir doch schon.
Was hat dich denn zu Persona Non Grata gemacht?
Teilnahme an der sogenannten Terroristischen Vereinigung, 2. Juni. Ich bin dann irgendwann unter, naja, natürlich auf dem Steckbriefel landet, also wie damals diese schönen Steckbriefe, ja. Und die vier schöner waren wie die neun. Die neun sind ja sehr ästhetisch, sehr hässlich.
Hängen die eigentlich wieder in Postentrennungen? Ich erinnere mich, als ich klein war hier in Postentrennen.
Ja, wieso hängen die nirgendswo aus? Wieso? Was ist überhaupt? Diese Steckbriefe sind ja, das fängt schon an mit Informationen. Wieso sind diese Leute auf den Steckbriefen?
Wieso warst du drauf? Also war dir was nachzuweisen?
Ja, es gab Leute, die haben, also eigene Leute, die sind verhaftet worden von der Polizei, die haben ausgesagt und dadurch waren wir klar.
Aber mit der RAF, da hast du eben drauf gestanden, da hattest du nichts zu tun.
Ich doch, wir haben mit der RAF zusammen Aktionen gemacht, aber ich war nicht Mitglied von der RAF.
Was unterscheidet den den 2. Juni von der RAF?
Wir waren mehr anarchistisch.
Und die RAF dann doch eher kommunistisch-sozialistisch?
Kommunistisch, ja, rote Armee-Fraktion, die uns sehr namisch und düster ahnen lässt.
Gut, dann warst du an diversen Anschlägen beteiligt und hast dich dann nach Afghanistan abgesetzt?
Ich bin es gehabt, weil wir davor bei den Haschrebellen, Zentralrat der umherschweifenden Haschrebellen, auch mit gegründet habe. Und da haben es Leute, die natürlich Haschisch aus Afghanistan geholt haben, damals schon. Und die haben dann gesagt, wenn du hier gesucht wirst, geh doch runter, da unten ist kein Problem. Und bin halt runtergefahren und fand es eigentlich sehr angenehm, also sehr entspannt.
Wann war das?
1972.
Also als Afghanistan auch tatsächlich noch nicht im Schutt und Aschelag.
Da war noch der König dran, den sie jetzt wieder ranbringen wollten.
Hälst du das für eine gute Idee? Du kennst das Land?
Der Mann war damals schon zu sprach, sich durchzusetzen. Jetzt ist er 87. Also 20 Jahre später, wie soll er sich jetzt durchsetzen? Also weil die Probleme sind, dass eigentlich eine Stammesgesellschaft ist. Die Leute denken ja, das ist ein Staat. Die stellen sich jetzt einen Staat vor, so wie hier in Deutschland oder in Europa, ist in keiner Weise. Das ist das Problem.
Also das Einzige, was Afghanistan zum Staat macht, ist eine definierte Grenze, die aber auch wahrscheinlich jemand einhält.
Ne, eine Grenze haben sie, die es definiert. Das Einzige, was es Afghanistan gemacht hat, ist die Grenze. Afghanistan wurde geschaffen wegen der Grenze. Also es ist ein Problem, der Großmächte Russland und England gewesen. 1800 rum, Mitte 1800, hat Russland sich ausgedehnt, weil er dazu in Alarie war, konnte Eisenbahnen bauen und England. Und so genannte Great Game hat angefangen. Das heißt, das große Spiel zwischen Russland und England, um den Einfluss in Zentralasien. Und jeder wollte natürlich seine Profite absetzen. Das sind imperialistische Planspiele gewesen. Und es ist zu einer Pattsituation rausgelaufen, weil quasi die Gründung Afghanistans bedeutet hat. Sie haben gesagt, wir bauen hier uns ein Pufferstaat. Ihr geht bis dahin, oben im Norden seht ihr. Und wir sind im Osten und im Süden. Und überschreitet einer die Grenze, wissen wir Bescheid.
Es ist quasi wie bei Raumschiff Enterprise die neutrale Zone.
Richtig, eine neutrale Zone, die zwischen Persien, den Kanaten hießen die früher, was heute Tajikistan ist, Turkmenistan, Uzbekistan waren sogenannte Kanate. Also da herrschten feudale, absolute Herrscher mittelalterlicher Prägung. Und Afghanistan ist nicht weiter eine reine Agrarkultur, wirtschaftlich, die unter den Königfingen an so leichte in Kabul und vielleicht ein bisschen in Kanar Leichtindustrie. Also zum Beispiel habt ihr fantastische Kabul Plastic Works. Das waren die ersten, die Plastiksandalen durchsichtlich mit Glitter innen hergestellt haben.
Die sind ja jetzt wieder modern.
Die haben sich zum Beispiel Gucci Schuhe aus ein paar, aus Italien geholt und haben die dann nachgebaut in allen Farben. Kabul Plastic war damals ein ganz für Insider Träschig und waren so die Einzelnen und ein paar Minen für Lapis Lazuli Steine und ein bisschen Jolt. Haben sie von eigentlich einer Agrar-Struktur mit sehr wenig Industrie an zwei Plätzen und Abbau von Bodenschätzen. Und die regelt über ein Staatswesen, was also quasi in den meisten Gebieten nicht vorhanden war oder nur durch Militär durchsetzbar war, weil Stammesgebiete abgesichert wurden durch die Klanschaft der Stämme, durch Großgrundbesitzer, durch Mullers und die sind meistens identisch gewesen. Also dieselbe Situation ist heute wieder, dass der Muller ist auch gleichzeitig der Großgrundbesitzer und einer der Oberen in den jeweiligen Stamm. Und die Verhalten, also die Problem heute ist eigentlich geblieben, dass die sich jetzt durchgesetzt haben nach 20 Jahren Krieg, weil die eigentlichen Taliban ausmachen, ist eigentlich eine Großgrundbesitzerkaste, die gleichzeitig die Geisttierführerschaft beansprucht und dadurch ihren Profit Margen absichern. Also Leute, die eigentlich rechtsaußen von Ludwig XIV angesiedelt sind. So ungefähr muss man die sich vorstellen.
Der Mann, der da spricht, ist Bommi Baumann. Bommi Baumann hat in den 70er Jahren 10 Jahre in Afghanistan verbracht und dürfte darum als Afghanistankennner bezeichnet werden. Wir sehen uns dann hier im Chaosradio 66 auf Fax.
Ja, die Frage nach der Musik war aufgetaucht. Das ist Muslim Gauss. Ich weiß nicht schrecklich viel über die. Ich hab mir gerade irgendwie, ich glaube, 15 CDs von denen.
Arabische Stühler von Karlheinz Stockhausen.
Ja, offensichtlich.
Möglicherweise. Die haben schon auch irgendwas mit der Palästinenser zu tun. Und die, die wir gerade hören, das ist die Hand of Fatima. Diese Musik soll schwer zu bekommen sein, hab ich ihm ja sagen lassen.
Ja, also ich hab's mal versucht und es war sogar mir weitestgehend unmöglich, das zu bekommen, obwohl wir hier ein Archiv haben. Wo waren wir stingen geblieben? Wir waren Entstehungsgeschichte und überhaupt Sozialstruktur Afghanistan.
Sozialstruktur, das heißt also eigentlich sind Erzreaktionäre, Feudale, Agrarische, mittelalterliche Interessen, die da verteidigt werden. Von diesen Leuten, die sich jetzt Taliban nennen und diese gesamte Koalition dieser Leute. Also die haben keinerlei Fortschritt. Fortschritt Kapitalismus ist ja eine revolutionäre Bewegung. Also die Leute denken, Kapitalismus ist staatlich, ist er ja nicht. Er verändert ja Strukturen zu seinen Vorteilen. Ja, und diese Veränderung würde ja bedeuten, früher oder später, dass sie weggewischt werden. Also sind so klipp und klar gegen jeden westlichen Einfluss, weil er würde ihre Profite schmälern, ihren Machtzuwachs behindern. Also irgendwann werden sie an seine Seite gedrückt. Das ist den Leuten schon klar. So weit haben sie eine Vorstellung.
Das erkennen wir und das erkennen natürlich auch die Taliban, also die, die das Zepter geändert haben. Die Bevölkerung erkennt das aber nicht.
Du musst dir vorstellen, es gibt kaum Strom in den Dörfern. Es gibt also quasi war nachher war ein Kassetten-Recorder eigentlich der große Hit.
Also wir reden jetzt über Ende der 70er, Anfang der 18er.
Bis in die 18er und dann kam ja der Krieg. Also Kassetten-Recorder waren der Hit, dass die Leute ins Dorf sich einen Kassetten-Recorder erholt haben, um Musik zu hören. Und dann haben sie, es gibt den Push-To-Service, also in der Sprache, oder Dari, also der BBC sendet natürlich. Immer, es ist immer gehört worden, eigentlich war BBC die große Bezirksquelle der Uhr zur Welt, weil Leute in London, also über die Vergangenheit der Engländer, waren immer Redakteure in London, die in den drei großen Landessparen Farsi, Dari und Push-To eine Stunde am Tag gesendet haben. Das war eigentlich die große Geschichte. Also wenn jetzt große Sachen passiert sind, haben alle am Radio gesessen und haben BBC gehört in ihrer Sprache. Ich war also da, als der russische Einmarsch war, ich war da, als Ubuntu im Pakistan entmachtet haben, als der König gestürzt wurde, als die jeweils immer an neuen kommunistischen Regime gestürzt wurden. Also ich habe immer diese Umstürze mitgekriegt und jedes Mal haben die Leute den BBC gehört. Also wo ein Radio erreichbar war, war eigentlich der BBC, die große Nachrichtenquelle, selbst so ein Sprecher, der ist inzwischen ein alter Mann, der ist einer der bekanntesten Männer in Afghanistan, die Stimme kennt jeder. Das ist so wie hier für uns früher John Peel. Oder für die, die in 15 Jahren groß geworden sind, George Hudeck von EFN. Eine Stunde Rack'n'Roll am Tag. EFN, Merkel Forces Network, George Hudeck. Und so haben die da ihre Sprecher. Und Zeitungen in Afghanistan, weil hohe Analphabeten und so gut wie nur in den Städten früher Kabul und Kandahar.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt, also setzen wir mal voraus, dass die US-amerikanischen Militärschläge erfolgreich sind, die Taliban werden entmachtet. Da hat auch dann wirklich, also eigentlich hat auch dann niemand eine Chance, dieses Land in irgendeiner Form zu befrieden und zu einigen, oder?
Ist extrem schwierig, also sagen selbst die, die jetzt heute ist im BBC zum Beispiel, ein sehr feher Kommandeur, der weder Taliban, weder Nordallianz ist. Samuel Haag, der ist ein ziemlich guter Soldat gewesen und den haben die Taliban und die gesamte Familie ausgerottet und der ist jetzt wieder gekommen und versucht, so irgendwie eine Allianz unter den Push-Tus hinzukriegen, was sehr schwierig ist, weil jeder...
Push-Tus sind jetzt...
Also die Pathanen sind immer die größte Bevölkerungsanteil.
Also das ist was bei uns im Fernsehen Pastunen heißt?
Richtig. Ja, die haben eben, du musst sehen, dass immer kommt die Familie, der Clan, der Stamm und dann kommt vielleicht die Vorstellung, wir sind Afghanis. Also Afghanistan für Afghanis kommt letztendlich immer an vierte Stelle und denn jetzt die einzelnen Zuordnungen laufen eigentlich immer, wer ist gerade an der Macht, mit wem arrangieren wir uns am besten oder wer dient unseren Interessen eigentlich am besten. Also ein Verhältnis, Afghanistan ist von der Machtstruktur am besten zu begreifen via Corleone. Diese selben Denken letztendlich, wenn man in Italien lange, die selben irgendwie wie Mafia-Clans ihre Claims verwalten. Im Grunde genommen hat es eine selbe Mentalität und wenn es denn nicht geht, dann eben mit Gewalt, also die kommt dann locker von der Hand.
Hättest du ein Rezept, wie vorzugehen wäre, falls ein Krieg siegreich für die sogenannte zivilisierte Welt ausgehen würde?
Ja, welcher Krieg ist sinnvoll? Die sehen ja ihre Sache auch als zivilisiert an.
Zumindest als ethisch einwandfrei.
Also A, man zweischneidet Schwert. B, von allen Erfahrungen weiß es im Augenblick niemand. Also jeder, der behauptet, er kriegt, so wie unser begnadeter Außenminister, der sagt, wir kriegen ja vernünftige Verhältnisse hin, ist entweder dumm oder lügt. Das machen wir uns nicht vor. Keiner, auch die Leute vor Ort, wissen es im Augenblick nicht.
Wer wäre denn ein gemäßigter Führer in Afghanistan, der tatsächlich von allen oder von einem Maximum an Bevölkerungsgruppen akzeptiert würde? Gibt es da überhaupt jemanden?
Also dieser König ist als irgendwie Einjungsfigur für alle Außenstehenden denkbar. Von der Praxis her ist er letztendlich nicht. Er ist zu alt, zu schwach und er fängt jetzt schon an Fehler zu machen, dass er sich Loyalität erkauft. Jetzt kriegt die UNO und die Amerikaner haben ihn wieder Geld geben. Und nun fängt er an, sich gewisse Loyalitäten zu kaufen. Die Afghanen haben ein Ding, das heißt der große Stammesrat, die große Jury hat. Das heißt, alle Stammesältesten kommen zusammen und entscheiden. Tagelang Debatten. Und er fängt jetzt an, sich für diese Versammlung Leute zu kaufen und nicht nach Kompetenz oder nach wirklichen Einfluss, den die haben. Und da wird es schon los. Also da ist abzusehen.
Es müsste tatsächlich, um zivilisatorische Verhältnisse zu schaffen, erst mal dieser abstrakte Volksbegriff in die Bevölkerung Afghanistans reingebracht werden.
Ja, den haben die Taliban grundsätzlich zerschlagen. Dass sie also grundsätzlich auch rassistisch vorgegangen sind. Das heißt, sie haben nur eine patternische Mehrheit regiert. Also die alten Völker, die anderen Völker, die Tajiken und die Usbeken, hatten nichts zu sagen. Darum sind sie in der Nordallianz zum Teil. Und diesen Zusammenhalt, der Leichtaber, diese Vorstellung Afghaner, haben die Taliban natürlich noch mal zusätzlich zerschlagen. Die haben in den fünf Jahren, oder wie lange sind die jetzt dran? Ungefähr für jährliche fünf Jahre. Haben die diesen Zusammenhalt noch mal zerkloppt. Also ist die Situation schwieriger denn je. Also alle Leute, die jetzt heutzutage, wenn da Lösungen auf den Tisch kommen, wissen wirklich nicht, wovon sie reden. Das ist meine Meinung. Also ich halte es für einen kompletten Schwachsinn, wenn einer uns erzählt, der dann machen wir es so, dann kommt die UNO und dann wird der da hinten eingesetzt und die kriegen geht. Also weil eine Lolealität ist unter Afghanen, ist es nicht lange haltbar. Wenn der sieht, er hat irgendwo einen Vorteil, so ein Clan-Chef, dann fängt er an plötzlich zur anderen Seite zu rudern.
Das heißt, sind das eher unehrenhafte Menschen? Das kann man nicht sagen.
Sie sind schon auf ihre Art, aber das ist...
Vielleicht kein westliches Ehrgefühl?
Eben diese mafiöse C-Aranjarsi, man arrangiert sich. Man arrangiert sich eben nach allen Seiten. Und dieser Prozess ist fließend. Da ist ja auch nicht das Aufwandbecken, jetzt irgendwie Staat, Gesetz, Gesellschaft, ist ja nicht. Eine Stamme ist geteilt in Sprachen, geteilt in Gebiete. Und die wieder zusammenzukriegen, würde Jahre dauern. Du hast noch eine Schwierigkeit, abgesehen von Versorgung, du hast riesige Gebiete vermint. Keiner weiß, wo die Minen sind, wie sie oft zu spüren sind, weil die Russen zum Schluss Plastikminen abgeschmissen haben. Also ein zusätzlicher Stress, den nirgendswo auf der Welt gibt. Kein Land der Welt ist so farmin wie Afghanistan.
Nach den Nachrichten reden wir weiter, Chaosradio 66 auf FritzSzim. Musik von Muslim Gauz heute im Chaosradio 66. Muslim Gauz geschrieben, falls ihr es irgendwo im Internet mal nachschlagen wollt. Relativ schwer zu kriegen, ihr könnt ja ein Band mitlaufen lassen, wir reden auch gerne die ganze Zeit drüber.
Wenn Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
22.30 Uhr ist es jetzt und die Jingle-Maschine hat mich im Stich gelassen. Das Leben ist manchmal wirklich kein Wunschkonzert. Aber das ist mir von mir ja gewohnt, dass ich mit dem Gerät nicht umgehen kann. 22.31 Uhr.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Mit dem Wetter. Nachts etwas Regen bei 9 bis 5 Grad morgen, dann wolkenreich bei 12 bis maximal 15 Grad. Die Meldung jetzt mit Bastian Boerner.
Bei dem schwersten Tunnelunglück in der Geschichte der Schweiz gehen die Behörden inzwischen von bis zu 20 Toten aus. Am Abend bragen Rettungskräfte zehn Opfer aus dem Gotthardtunnel. Die meisten von ihnen seien erstickt, hieß es. Die USA wollen ihre Angriffe auf Afghanistan auch im bevorstehenden Winter fortsetzen. Außenminister Paul erklärte, es gehe nicht um Zeitlimit, sondern darum, die gesteckten Ziele zu erreichen. Er wies zugleich Forderungen zurück, nach denen die Angriffe während des Fastenmonats Ramadan eingestellt werden sollten. Rund 10.000 Menschen haben heute in Potsdam gegen die geplanten Kürzungen im Bildungsetat des brandenburgischen Landeshaushalts demonstriert. Dazu hatte die Gewerkschaft Erziehung und Wissenschaft aufgerufen. Bundesfinanzminister Eichel hat im Streit um die Erhöhung der Tabaksteuer nachgegeben. Die Steuer soll nun nicht in einem, sondern in zwei Schritten angehoben werden. Zunächst soll sie bis zum 1. Januar um knapp zwei Pfennig pro Zigarette steigen. Die zweite Annehmung folgt ein Jahr später. Und jetzt zum Sport. Der deutsche Basketballmeister Albert Berlin bleibt auf internationalem Parkett siedlos. Am dritten Spieltag der Euroleague-Unterlagen wie Berliner bei FS Istanbul mit 68 zu 72 nach der dritten Niederlage in Folge sind die Chancen der Albatrosse auf das Erreichen der Zwischenrunde auf ein Minimum gesunken.
Zigarettchen, Bastian?
Ja, ich glaube, das brauche ich jetzt auch gleich. Aber der Verkehr auf Fritz A100. Stadtringen zwischen Dreieck Tempelhof und Pritzer Damm bis Ende des Monats, Sperrung der linken Spurenrichtung. Treptow Kreuzberg in der Kreuzung, Friedrich- und Kochstraße bis Ende des Monats, Behinderung wegen Bauarbeiten. Brandenburg B167, Bad Freienwalde, Löwenberg zwischen Eberswalde und Fienowfurt bis Mitte Dezember, Vollsperrung wegen einer Baustelle. Umleitungen sind aber beschildert, Stadtverkehr Potsdam, Breite Straße zwischen Schopenhauer Straße und Langer Brücke bis Mitte Dezember, Behinderung in beiden Richtungen, das Linksabbiegen in die Dortowstraße ist nicht möglich.
Weiß Vater davon, danke Basian. Wenn du den Kopfhörer aufhältst, dann würdest du dich selber hören, Bommi. Chaosradio 66 auf Fritz ist hier zu Gast im Studio Bommi Baumann. Der hat 10 Jahre, richtig? Zehn Jahre. Ja, knapp zehn Jahre in Afghanistan gelebt und zwar die gesamten 70er und Anfang der 80er. Außerdem Jan und Thorsten von indymedia.org und M-Quadrat. Guten Abend, Andi, möchtest du das Zepter haben?
Nee, das möchte ich nicht. Soll ich andere Musik machen? Ja, du möchtest andere Musik machen, was wir jetzt hier machen. Wir haben ja gerade hier diesen Nachrichtensprecher drin gehabt, diesen jungen Mann, der offenbar den Terrorismus auch noch unterstützt. Er fragte, glaube ich, nach amerikanischen Zigaretten.
Wer hat nur Zigarette gesagt? Also amerikanische? Ich habe ihm eine F6 gegeben, die kommen aus Sachsen.
Alles klar, und da war ja in den Nachrichten diese Meldung, Herr Powell möchte jetzt also auch während des Winters dort...
Ich kann die gerne nochmal vortragen, die Meldung hieß, die USA wollen ihre Angriffe auf Afghanistan auch im bevorstehenden Winter fortsetzen. Außenminister Powell erklärte, es gehe nicht um Zeitlimits, sondern darum, die gesteckten Ziele zu erreichen. Er wies zu Gleichforderungen zurück, nach denen die Angriffe während des Fastenmonats Ramadan eingestellt werden sollten.
Wie ist denn der Winter in Afghanistan, Bommi?
Etwas härter wie hier. Ein Land ohne Straßen und quasi noch Wege. Es kann schlachartig innerhalb von einer Stunde ein Meter Schnee runterkommen. In Teland, wenn du in der Talsohle bist, heißt das, du hast ein echtes Problem, da wieder rauszukommen.
Das würde auch gleichzeitig heißen, keine Chance für die Flüchtlinge, die da gerade unterwegs sind, oder?
Für die ist keine Chance. Für jeden, der in Teland gefangen ist und wird schlachartig von den Schneewehen überfallen, hat eigentlich nicht mehr eine Überlebenschance.
Und wie stellen die US-Militärs sich das denn davor? Hast du da eine Ahnung?
Die US-Militärs stellen sich eigentlich vor, dass jetzt 2 bis 3 Millionen Menschen verhungern, weil sie Bomben schmeißen. Das ist das Endresultat. Da muss man einfach mal so krass sehen. Da wird jetzt ein Investmentbanker hochgerechnet auf ungefähr pro einen Investmentbanker gleich 1000 afghanische Kinder. Oder irgendeine wundersame Rechnung, die da beglichen wird jetzt.
Und wie realistisch ist es, dass die afghanischen Kinder daran schuld sind, dass das World Trade Center...
Null.
Na gut, dann müssen wir uns die Frage stellen, wie realistisch ist es, dass die Leute im World Trade Center daran schuld sind, was in Afghanistan passiert.
Dann passiert genauso, also die Frage ist die selbe.
Ja Moment, na die läuft ja ein bisschen komplizierter, weil eben kam kurz als das Mikro noch nicht an, weil ja die Frage auf, ist Afghanistan nicht eigentlich auch irgendwie in den Welthandel integriert? So und die Antwort ist ja, ja irgendwie schon. Allerdings nicht über die Dinge, die üblicherweise in Börsenkursen erfasst werden und ähnliches, sondern die Lieferung von RoOpium.
Als Drogenproduzent. Als Opiumproduzent ist Afghanistan Nummer 1.
Na gut, das wäre ja auch dann auch nur ein weiteres Argument, gegen Afghanistan Krieg zu führen, dass sie Drogen produzieren, weil das ist ja dann auch ein erklärtes Ziel, insbesondere konservativer Kräfte Drogen komplett auszumachen.
Wie heißt das schon, ihr Krieg gegen Drogen, jetzt haben wir den Krieg gegen Terror?
Ja das ist ja ganz toll. Ich meine, die Frage, die wir uns ja stellen können, ist, wie realistisch ist das, was wir da von den Amerikanern erfahren? Also ich meine, klar, die afghanische Bevölkerung, die jetzt gerade flüchtet und die natürlich jetzt nicht in den Medien gerade zum Beispiel die Bedeutung haben, wie wenn Bin Laden gerade einen Furz lässt und sagt irgendwie, ihr Amerikaner beantwortet doch mal meine Frage auf CNN oder irgendwie etwas. Also das Elend dieser Leute wird ja zum Beispiel gerade ein bisschen unter den Teppich gekehrt. Und die haben natürlich auch nicht die Medienpower. Ich weiß nicht, ich kann Indymedia uns da aushelfen, nehmen wir mal an. Ich will jetzt mal wissen, was da tatsächlich abgeht.
Vielleicht erklären wir erstmal, was Indymedia ist. Weil ich glaube, viele kennen es auch nicht.
Ja leider, leider kennen das viele nicht.
Sprich bitte ins Mikrofon.
Also gut, was ist Indymedia? Indymedia ist ein Netzwerk von freien medienschaffenden, freiwilligen Leuten, die in der Zwischenzeit weltweit vor allem Webseiten betreuen, auf denen nicht kommerzielle Nachrichten über allerlei veröffentlicht werden. Vor allem in Richtung Nachrichten, die halt von den Medien verschwiegen werden.
Was sind kommerzielle und was sind nicht kommerzielle Nachrichten?
Die Nachrichten an sich sind ja nicht kommerzielle und nicht kommerzielle. Es geht eher um den Nachrichtenssender, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Der Kommerzielle oder der Nicht-Kommerzielle ist irgendwie... Fritz ist ja irgendwie auch kein kommerzieller Nachrichtensender im Lebenssinn, aber durchaus ein gut bezahlter, mit fetten finanziellen Ressourcen und hat natürlich auch irgendwie einen Hintergrund, der irgendwie versorgt durch TPA und was auch immer. Und das ist auch gut so. Wir wollen dem was entgegenstellen, dass wir die Nachrichten, die wir produzieren oder nicht produzieren, zur Verfügung stellen. Nachrichten aus der Basisbewegung, aus den Bewegungen gegen zum größten Teil die Anti-Globalisierungsbewegung, die sogenannte, oder die globalisierungskritische Bewegung, wie sie in der Zwischenzeit haben.
Anti darf man nicht sein, dann kommt die Gedankenpolizei.
Vor allem, weil wir ja nicht gegen eine Globalisierung sind, Indymedia ist ein globales Netzwerk. Wenn wir gegen eine globalisierung wären, dann wäre das ein ziemlicher Schwachsinn.
Auf Indymedia bekomme ich quasi ungefilterte Nachrichten. Also nicht mit dem Blick eines Journalisten, der eine gewisse professionelle Rahmenbedingungen hat, sondern ihr schreibt einfach drauf los.
Professionelle Nachrichtenmacher wie Journalisten haben natürlich den gewissen Blick für die Verkaufbarkeit der Nachrichten, für die Objektivität, Breitenwirkung, Fressbarkeit. Fressbarkeit? Sie muss ja irgendwie vermittelt werden können und es muss auch gut sein, dass es auch die Bild-Zeitung veröffentlicht kann und ihr Killentee bedient Wirbeldien.
Was die Bild-Zeitung veröffentlicht, muss nicht gut sein. Also da hätte ich jetzt wieder sprechen müssen. Wen?
Kuno der Killerwelt, sie fand den gut.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht. Schön war auch, als Bush gesagt hat, er würde 1, 3 Billionen Dollar Steuern verschenken, hat die Bild-Zeitung daraus 3, irgendwas Billionen Mark gemacht, ohne dass sie gemerkt haben, dass die amerikanische Billion gerade mal eine Milliarde bei uns ist.
Ja, jetzt hast du einen Faden verloren.
Ja, ich meine, wir reden ja jetzt ein bisschen über verschiedene Medienrealitäten so und was mich mal jetzt konkret interessieren würde, vielleicht als Beispiel. Wir haben jetzt die Situation, dass zum Beispiel weltweit in der sogenannten westlichen Welt gerade die sogenannten Sicherheitsmaßnahmen irgendwie nach oben geschraubt werden, sich die Sicherheitspolitiker überbieten mit Vorschlägen, wie man die innere Sicherheit oder auch die äußere oder wie auch immer gewährleisten kann. Also ich sag mal, finde ich denn bei euch jetzt sozusagen gerade eine andere Realität? Oder wie sieht das sozusagen vom Endergebnis her aus? Ich kann jetzt hier irgendwie Internet klicken, dann habe ich spiegel.de, dann sehe ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Herr Powell verkündet dies und Herr Bin Laden verkündet das und Herr Schillie dreht durch. Aber das ist ja ein anderes Thema.
Das ist eine interessante Frage. Also die Medienrealität in Deutschland, also zumindest die öffentlich-rechtliche Medienrealität in Berlin-Brandenburg, sieht so aus, dass die erste Meldung, zumindest hier jetzt bei uns gerade, ein Tunnelunglück in der Schweiz war. Die zweite Meldung ist, die USA wollen die Angriffe auf Afghanistan fortsetzen. Die dritte Meldung wäre dann eine Demonstration gegen Kürzungen des Bildungsetats in Potsdam.
Die vierte war dann irgendwie schon Sport, ne?
Ne, das war Bundesfinanz... ne, wir sind hier nicht bei RTL 2. Die vierte war Bundesfinanzminister Tabaksteuer, die fünfte war Sport, aber das liegt doch daran, dass es hier Kurznachrichten waren.
Ich kann jetzt einfach mal als Alternative sagen, was unsere Top-Meldungen zurzeit sind.
Und wenn du es ins Mikrofon sagst, kann es auch jeder verstehen.
Unsere Top-Meldungen zurzeit sind Polizeiratsia gegen Online-Demonstrantinnen, eine Einschätzung, Diskussion des Attack-Kongresses vom Wochenende in Berlin, dann haben wir einen Diskussionstext, Leopardentraum, ich habe ihn noch nicht gelesen, deswegen kann ich überhaupt nicht sagen, was da drin steht. Dann haben wir eine Berichterstattung über das Make-World-Festival, ein Festival von alternativen Medien und Internetmachenden in München, einen Bericht über den Perlusconi-Besuch in Nürnberg und was auch immer. Das sind die Sachen, die wir in der Winterspalte haben. Dann haben wir noch die einzelnen Meldungen, die wir im sogenannten Newswire stehen haben. Das sind dann eine kleine Nachricht aus Afghanistan, Neues aus Afghanistan, da kann ich mal draufklicken. Was ist denn das? Oder zum Beispiel hatten wir gestern einen Bericht eines in Afghanistan befindlichen Arztes, der dort über die dortigen Zustände und die dortige Realität berichtet hat. Das sind durchaus keine professionellen Medienmacher, das sind Leute, die vor Ort sind, die die Realität mitbekommen. Das ist auch unser Konzept. Wir wollen von den Menschen, die in ihren Lebensumständen stehen, ihnen kämpfen oder was auch immer, was sie gerade so machen, dass sie ihre Realität in der Art und Weise der Öffentlichkeit darbringen. Und dafür wollen wir eine Plattform sein.
Würdest du Indymedia als realer bezeichnen, als die Medien, die man sonst wahrnimmt, also sprich öffentlich-rechtlichen privaten Rundfunk?
Was ist Realität? Das ist eine interessante Diskussion.
Also werde ich bei dir besser informiert? Oder werde ich nur anders informiert?
Ich würde sagen, wir haben einen anderen Blickwinkel. Den Blickwinkel auf die Basis oder den Blickwinkel von unten und eher am wenigsten den Blickwinkel, der betont objektiv rüberkommen will. Und das Rüberkommen ist aber eher der entscheidende Punkt bei der Objektivität und nicht das, was real dahinter steckt.
Chaosradio 66 auf Rütz mit Musik von Muslim-Gauze. Es ist 10 vor 11. Wir sprachen gerade über Indymedia. Das ist eine unabhängige Nachricht und Seite im Internet. www.indymedia.org und Jan und Thorsten von Indymedia. Jan, bist du jetzt quasi Chefredakteur? Oder wie stelle ich mir das vor?
Als Chefredakteur bin ich natürlich Chefredakteur. Jeder ist Chefredakteur von Indymedia. Das ist der entscheidende Punkt. Wie ist Indymedia organisiert? Vielleicht ist das ein Punkt, worauf wir raus wollen. Vielleicht mache ich einen kleinen geschichtlichen Ausflug. Bitte, nur zu. Es gab mal ein Fußballspiel in New York, das war im Sommer 1999. Da haben sich einige Video, Audio und was auch immer Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten getroffen. Wir haben über die Frage diskutiert. Es ist im November in Seattle eine WTO-Tagung. Da gibt es eine große Proteste. Da muss man Nachrichtenberichterstattung auf die Reihe bringen. Insgesamt kommen wir nicht so richtig gut rüber. Da müssen wir eine eigene Realität entgegenstellen. Wir haben dann kurzerhand beschlossen, diese Tagung in Seattle mit einem unabhängigen Medienzentrum, einem Independent Media Center, zu begleiten. Es wurde dann in kurzer Zeit die entsprechende Infrastruktur auf die Reihe gebracht. Selbst als dann in Seattle die Proteste waren, die der große Hype in der Weltgeschichte wurden danach. Das war die Geburtsstunde der Antiklopatisierungsbewegung. Die Kenntnisnahme dieser Proteste war, denke ich, in großem Teil sicherlich auch der Arbeit von den Leuten vor Ort in Seattle, dem Independent Media Center, zu verdanken. Sie haben täglich eine Video-Sendung gemacht, eine halbe Stunde lang über Satellit ausgestrahlt, Radio-Geschichten und natürlich eben diese mehr textuell und auf Bilder basierte Berichterstattung im Netz. Die Idee, die da irgendwie im Raum stand, hat sich natürlich sofort verbreitet. Die Leute, die dort vor Ort waren in Seattle, das waren halt nicht nur Leute aus Seattle, sondern auch aus New York und Washington DC und wo auch immer, und haben dann entsprechend in all den Städten weitere lokal basierte Medienzentren aufgebaut. Die Idee ist über den Tellerrand der USA hinübergeschwappt, nach Europa, nach Südamerika, nach Afrika, bis wir jetzt heute auf dem Status sind, dass wir, wenn ich mich richtig entzine, 67 Medienzentren haben, was zum Teil lokale, regional basierte Geschichten sind, oder in Europa eher auf Länder basierend. Es gibt jetzt ein Indymedia-Zentrum Deutschland, ein Indymedia-Zentrum Belgien, Niederlande, Norwegen, Schweden und so weiter. Italien.
Da ist es auch wirklich nötig, Entschuldigung.
Ja, definitiv. Was die Indymedia-Geschichte ausgemacht hat, waren vor allem die Begleitung dieser großen, globalisierungskritischen Kampagnen. Seattle, Washington DC, Quebec, Prag, Genua zuletzt, was dann auch so ein bisschen auf einer Art trauriger Höhepunkt war. Genua ist das Medienzentrum gestürmt worden von der Polizei. Unsere ganze Gerätschaft ist dort irgendwie zerhackt worden, zerhackt Stück worden. Einige Leute sind in den Knast gelandet und haben da doch irgendwie...
Ist da eigentlich nicht die italienische Verfassung dagegen, das Berichterstatter, geprügelt, obwohl das interessiert die Berliner Polizei auch nicht bei den Mai-Demonstrationen?
Ich glaube, die Mai-Demonstrationen sind dagegen doch ein bisschen ein Pappenstiel. Das war schon irgendwie nicht schön, was da passiert ist. Ich hoffe, ich übertreibe jetzt nicht. Nein, die italienischen Bullen sind hart. Klar, Indymedia war vor Ort in Genoa als offizielle Presseberichterstatter akkreditiert, irgendwie auch gegenüber der Polizei, gegenüber den öffentlichen Behörden. Das wurde überhaupt nicht zur Kenntnis gehören und auch ziemlich ignoriert. Das Indymediazentrum in Genoa war auch eigentlich der Anlaufpunkt für die Berichterstatter, die nicht nur auf die offiziellen Berichterstattungen, also die offiziellen Meldungen und was auch immer der Gipfelmacher angewiesen werden sein wollten, sondern auch mal Infos und Bilder und was auch immer abzocken wollten, die sie dann selbst verwendet wollten. Das war so der traurige Höhepunkt der letzten Zeit. Seitdem sprießt das ganze Ding irgendwie noch mehr aus dem Boden. Es werden immer mehr in die Medienzentren aufgebaut und das floriert ganz schön.
Werdet ihr denn von den klassischen Medien akzeptiert oder behandeln die euch eher so wie ein paar linke Spinner, die jetzt mal wieder den Maul aufreißen und agitieren wollen?
Na das kommt von Mal zu Mal, ist es anders irgendwie. Natürlich so einige Netzmedien wie die Telepolis und Heise machen dann schon auch gern mal einen Link zu uns. Den beantworten wir dann auch gern mal wieder mit einem Link von uns zu denen. Aber konjunkturell ist das verschieden. Also gerade bei so großen Ereignissen wie Genua, da werden wir dann schon oft mal bei BBC Online irgendwie auf der Stadtseite verlinkt.
Aber das ist doch dann schon quasi ein Ritterschlag, oder? Ein Ritterschlag.
Ein Ritterschlag.
Ich meine BBC, hey.
Ja, das ist nicht schlecht. Ja. Kann man nicht merken.
Dann ist es auf einem guten Weg. Seit wann gibt es euch?
Wie gesagt, seit 1999 November. Also in Deutschland gibt es das jetzt seit, lass mal überlegen, April, April, ne? Wir haben uns im Winter des, also Winter 2000, 2001 in Hamburg in einem kalten, kalten Häuschen getroffen und beschlossen, dass wir das jetzt aufbauen wollen, anlässlich der Kassertransporte im April. Und das war so die Initialzündung. Dann irgendwie dort auch, auch da haben wir dann auch ziemlich viel Esstanz bekommen.
Ich wollte nur fragen, habt ihr jetzt zu diesem aktuellen sozusagen Spannungsfeld, oder wie wir das jetzt auch mal nennen, was da gerade zwischen Amerika und anderen Ländern passiert, habt ihr da so eine Art, keine Ahnung, ihr seid ja in vielen Ländern, gibt es da sozusagen, wie läuft diese Kooperation zwischen den Ländern? Oder wie sind sozusagen diese unterschiedlichen Quellenlagen jetzt und Berichte aus Deutschland oder aus anderen Ländern, wie sind die jetzt miteinander vermengt? Sind das zusammen parallel Existenz oder gibt es da irgendwie auf dieser Orgebene? Ich habe neulich einen Flyer in der Hand gehabt, da war ich ein bisschen erschrocken, da habe ich gelesen, ja Indymedia, Org, blablabla. Und es ist sichergestellt, dass in den einzelnen Ländern da nicht mal ein Server wegkommt, also dass da einfach mal ein Beschlagnahm wirkt oder irgendwas, weil es einen Zentralserver in den USA gibt. Und da dachte ich, aber jetzt gerade in dieser Situation, einen Zentralserver in den USA zu haben, ist nicht sicher, ob irgendwie USA gerade das Land ist, was einen Freibericht erstattet und so richtig in allen Aspekten wünscht.
Nicht wirklich, also das haben sie ja auch zugegeben, dass sie darum bitten, dass nicht mehr unabhängig berichtet wird.
Habt ihr da sozusagen, jetzt kannst du mal erklären, wie das jetzt in dieser Situation gerade bei euch funktioniert? Technisch, oder insgesamt, wie ist das organisiert bei uns?
Wir haben, also jetzt mal rein auf der Deutschland-Ebene, haben wir glaube ich irgendwie in der Zwischenzeit sieben oder acht Mailing-Listen, auf denen irgendwie bis zu 150 Postings haben, die irgendwie über die Runde gehen, da werden Entscheidungen getroffen, Diskussionen geführt und was auch immer. Es gibt internationale Koordinierungs-Mailing-Listen, wo wir zum Beispiel über die Artikel auf der Stadtseite, auf der www.indymedia.org diskutieren. Dort werden die Texte durchaus diskutiert. Es gibt andere Entscheidungsstrukturen, es gibt Aufgabenbezogene, in den Mailing-Listen vor allem, einen permanent laufenden Chat, auf dem wir natürlich auch koordiniert handeln. Bei so speziellen Ereignissen, wie gerade am 11. September, liefen die US-amerikanisch genannten Breaking News einfach über den Chat raus und wir haben herausgefummelt, was wir haben wollten. Ähnlich läuft das mit anderen Ereignissen. Es wird natürlich Content geshared. Wir sind auf der anderen Seite technisch leider noch ein bisschen am hadern. Das ist eine Sache, woran wir ganz stark arbeiten. Dass wir definitiv sagen können, hier dieser Artikel auf Israel, dort in die Media-Org, der ist echt super toll, den wollen wir sofort haben. Es gibt zum Beispiel Übersetzungslisten, wo Leute, die mehr oder weniger professionell übersetzen können, angefragt werden. Dann schickst du eine Mail hin, hier der israelische Text, den brauchen wir jetzt mal kurz auf Deutsch. Gibt es denn jemand, der den übersetzen kann? Dann findet sich manchmal jemand, der das macht. Englisch, Französisch ist natürlich viel leichter. Und so läuft das dann.
Gibt es denn bei euch eine Art inhaltliche Struktur? Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf Indymedia gehe und sage, ich möchte jetzt gerne Informationen über dieses oder jenes Land, was ich jetzt bereisen will oder was mich jetzt interessiert, oder wie ist da so eine Orientierung als Außenstehende? Ich bin ja jetzt nicht sozusagen Redakteur bei euch, sondern ich bin als erst mal nur Nutzer oder wie ja diese Menschen auch immer nennen, vor den Geräten. Du meinst jetzt, wie ist das mit Ihnen, mit der Struktur?
Alles Inhalt, oder?
Ja, alles Inhalt, aber genau. Also mein Problem ist irgendwie, also mein Eindruck ist, ich hänge ja irgendwie auch in ungefähr 30 Mailing-Listen. Ich habe 300-400 Mails am Tag so. Ich bin wahrscheinlich schon gut informiert, aber mein Problem ist oft dann eher so, okay, jetzt will ich aber mal genau eine ganz bestimmte Sache wissen und der Prozess dann genau zu dieser Information hier zu kommen. Ich glaube, das ist auch das, was das Internet so ein bisschen ausmacht. So Information ist jetzt da wie Luft, aber das dann eben zu finden, was man gerade will. Das ist dann eben die Kunst. Und die Frage ist, wie begegnet ihr diesem Problem? Weil wenn du sagst, ihr habt da alleine schon so ein paar hundert Mails, wo ihr sozusagen diese Diskussion führt, dann könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass es da auch einen gewissen Informationsüberlastmoment gibt, wo man dann selbst, wenn man will, Probleme hat, das eben zu finden, was man sucht.
Da triffst du uns an einem Punkt. Also, brauchst du dich nicht entschuldigen. Klar, wir haben eine Suchmaschine. Also, bei der deutschen Seite indizieren wir das alles irgendwie mit einer ganz netten Suchmaschine. Wir haben verschiedene technische Systeme am Laufen, deswegen ist das nicht alles identisch. Allerdings, wie gesagt, Archivstrukturen, wo man richtig schön katalogmäßig nach was suchen kann, existieren noch nicht. Wir sind da auch stark am Arbeiten in der Hinsicht Katalogisierung und wie auch immer der Nachrichten. Das ist eine Heidenarbeit. Und das ist auch der größte Teil der Arbeit, die Indymedia-Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten machen. Wir haben Themengebiete, Schwerpunktgebiete. Es gibt zum Beispiel jetzt gerade, also kampagnenorientiert, immer wieder Spezialseiten wie indymedia.org/peace, wo wir Hintergrundnachrichten, Artikel, letzte Neuigkeiten, wo steht noch was, verlinkt haben. Ähnliche Geschichten gibt es zu Ökologie. Da gibt es sogar eine Spezial-Webseite für, ja, also climate.indymedia.org, das ist so ein Klimakonferenzbetreuer gewesen, es läuft jetzt auch weiter und so in der Art ist das derzeit organisiert. Wir sind irgendwie, das ist auch eine Diskussion, ein stetiger Prozess, dass wir irgendwie auch themenorientierte Seiten aufziehen, wo wir sagen, ok, hier gibt es wirklich nur Informationen zu Antirassismus oder zu bestimmten Regionen oder was auch immer.
Und habt ihr dann, ich sage mal, ihr bewegt euch ja zumindest mit dem Anspruch jetzt auch an Bereichen zu berichten, wo eben zum Beispiel bei diesen WTO-Gipfeln, also bei der World Trade Organization, da wird ja auch ähnlich wie jetzt in diesem Kriegsgeschehen, auch wenn man das vielleicht nicht miteinander vergleichen sollte, versucht, so eine Informationshoheit zu erzeugen. Hier ist die offizielle Berichterstattung und ansonsten ein paar Metapolizei und that's it. Habt ihr dann sozusagen jetzt mal abgesehen vor diesen körperlichen Auseinandersetzungen gehen, dass sie dann tatsächlich mit dem Knüppel auf eure Computer einschlagen, habt ihr das auch auf der Informationsebene? Also habt ihr da schon den Eindruck, dass da auch die Information Operations, der entsprechenden Geheimnisse kommen, und euch dann einfach mal eine Runde Scheiße ins Netz laden oder? Also das erlebt man ja auf bestimmten Mailing, das hat man dann zu bestimmten Ereignissen, schalten sich dann auf einmal bestimmte Leute ein, die also in einer Länge da ein Kram auf einmal anfangen, sich miteinander zu streiten, wo man sich fragen könnte, ist das jetzt irgendwie gerade der Wahrheitsfindung sozusagen hilfreich oder ist es... Ja, also... Oder ist das eine Verschwörungstheorie-Frage?
Ich würde das jetzt erst mal ein bisschen in die Ecke Verschwörungstheorie setzen. Ich denke, aber es gibt auf eine Art, gibt es natürlich definitiv Punkte, wo die staatlichen Behörden jetzt auch eher in Person eines frustrierten Polizeibeamten, der irgendwie am Abend aus dem Wendland zurückkommt, irgendwie dort den ganzen Tag dort dagegen gerockert ist, dann einfach seinen Frust im Forum unter einem Artikel ablässt und sagt, ihr seid doch alle linke Spinner oder was auch immer und rumschimpft. Aber das ist ja eigentlich eher besandt. Das ist auch so ein Punkt, auf eine Art. In Genua hatten wir glaube ich auch den Punkt, dass sich dort die dortige Polizeibehörden zum Teil eingeschaltet haben als Polizeibeamte, die nach dem Einsatz so ein bisschen gesurft sind auf der Wache oder wie auch immer. Solche Sachen kommen vor.
Haben die sich entschuldigt oder haben sich gerechtfertigt?
Die haben sich eher gerechtfertigt oder haben natürlich gerechtfertigt in dem Sinne, dass sie auf eine böse Buben woanders hingeschoben sind.
Was ich interessant finde, hat sich irgendwann mal die italienische Regierung bei euch entschuldigt oder hat es irgendwelche Konsequenzen für die Regierung oder für die Polizei in Italien?
Es ist die Zeit im Laufen. Es war am Montag, sind einige Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach Italienbrunnen gefahren, um dort vorm Untersuchungsrichter auszusagen über genau jeden Überfall. Das ist im Laufen. Was da rauskommt, wahrscheinlich nichts. Aber trotz alledem, solche Sachen kommen schon zustande.
23 Uhr und ein paar Minuten, um genau zu sein. Und zwar das Chaos Radio 66. Ich bin gespannt, was ihr da so in der Sendung habt. Ich bin gespannt, ihr da so in der Sendung habt. Was war gegen öffentlich, nee was haben wir, was war unser Thema? Ich vergess immer den Satz.
Unser Thema ist so ein bisschen die Berichterstattung der Medien in Krisenzeiten und alternative Quellen und Gegenöffentlichkeit.
Gegenöffentlichkeit in Krisenzeiten, genau.
Die eben aus kommerziellen und sonstigen Beweggründen gestaltet werden.
Papst und gegen Papst in Krisenzeiten. Wir haben jetzt gerade einen kleinen Link auf die Fritz-Homepage gepackt. www.fritz.de slash computer. Da gibt es einen Link zu Contra Motion. Das ist tatsächlich unabhängige Basisberichterstattung aus der Krisenregion, aus der Kriegsregion, um Afghanistan herum. Also wenn ihr liebe...
Na ja, also wie bei der CRE unabhängig ist...
Na ja gut, dann ist der...
Nennen wir es Erstand Berichterstattung. Also das ist eine Seite von mir, wo ich gerade ein bisschen damit herumspiele, Quellen und Nachrichten. Ohne, dass ich die da selbst auf den Server schmeiß, sondern einfach nur Linksammlungen zu machen, die aber eben sehr strukturiert sind. In diesem Fall sind das eben Quellen, die einfach jetzt lokale Nachrichten, Sender, Zeitungen und ähnliches, die eben da in der Region ansässig sind. Aus Afghanistan, aus Pakistan, aus Indien, sogar Israel, Palästina und so weiter und so fort. Die habe ich zusammen mit Bommi erstellt, weil der halt die Gegend da ein bisschen kennt. Und man das auch so ein bisschen einschätzen kann, da gibt es natürlich auch welche, die so ein bisschen eher religiös orientiert sind von diesen Sendern und andere sind eher staatlich orientiert. Und dritte wiederum werden von der CIA betrieben, auch wenn sie angeblich aus der Region dort stammen. Tja, und jetzt stellt sich natürlich, also das findet ihr jetzt alles mal, da könnt ihr euch selber mal ein bisschen rumklicken. Die Frage, die wir natürlich auch mit euch diskutieren wollen, da draußen an den Hörern und auch an den Telefonen ist, fühlt ihr euch dann irgendwie sinnvoll informiert gerade?
Gerade von den klassischen Medien, wie Fritz ja im Prinzip eins ist. Also fühlt ihr euch ausreichend informiert oder würdet ihr euch andere Informationen oder mehr Informationen wünschen? Und vor allen Dingen, welche Art sollten denn die Informationen sein? Dann ruft uns an und sagt es uns. Keine Antwort, ist auch eine Antwort. Offensichtlich fühlt sich jeder ausreichend informiert, ansonsten würde er sich eben beklagen.
Die Telefonnummer, du musst ja nicht...
Die hab ich durchsagen, wenn du einen Kopfhörer hast, das war mir der letzte Blick. Ich habe nämlich eine elektrisch abspielbare Stimme eines jungen Mannes, der sagt folgendes...
0331, Telefonnummer.
Du hast immer noch keinen Kopfhörer auf.
Ich hab immer noch keinen Kopfhörer auf.
0331 77 97 110. Uns würde interessieren, ob ihr euch für gut informiert haltet oder ob euch ein bisschen mehr, ein bisschen andere Informationen fänden. Welcher Art denn lieber wäre als das, was wir öffentlich-rechtlichen, privaten Medien in Deutschland oder weltweit auch dieser Tage in der Lage sind zu liefern. 0331 77 97 110.
Und was wir gerade hier noch mal kurz zu nebenbei diskutiert haben, als wir gerade diesen Link auf die Fritz-Seite gemacht haben, ist bitte dreh doch nicht an diesen Regler. Du sprengst mir gerade das Gehör, Alter. Ja, das liegt eventuell daran, dass so ein Ding auf die Ohren sitzt. Okay, das ist der Stecker, der hier wackelt. Wir hatten jedenfalls gerade überdiskutiert, nennen wir diese Linkseite jetzt da Quellen aus dem Krisengebiet, nennen wir die Quellen aus dem Kriegsgebiet.
Na ja, da ist Krieg, also ist es ein Kriegsgebiet, oder?
Ja, ich meine, okay, das kann man natürlich so nennen, aber alleine schon diese Begriffe, wenn man jetzt sagt, das ist ein Krieg, dann könnte man ja fragen, gegen wen denn eigentlich? Also ich meine, abgesehen davon, dass Amerika keinen Krieg erklärt hat, das muss man auch mal sagen, normalerweise erklärt man Krieg, dann sagt man, okay, we are at war.
Aber Kriege gab es ja auch schon lange nicht mehr, es gab ja seit einiger Zeit keine Kriege mehr.
Ach so, das sind dann nur Waffentests, oder wie nennt man das?
Der Überfall, diese Irak-Geschichte damals, 1991, das war ja auch kein Krieg, sondern es war auch nur eine Krisenlösung.
Ja, und es sind Krisenlösungen, es sind Kampagnen, obwohl ja, was mich irgendwie verblüfft, sämtliche Medien tatsächlich sich so eine Kriegsrhetorik angewöhnt haben, ohne direkt vom Krieg zu sprechen. Also es ist auch eine sehr subversive Art und Weise der Bevölkerung schmackhaft zu machen, dass es gut ist, Bomben zu werfen.
Ich gucke gerade mal nach, ob das stimmt, aber die Frage ist ja, können die Amerikaner diesen Krieg gewinnen, und wenn ja, was können sie denn da gewinnen? Also ich habe mir sagen lassen, in Afghanistan gibt es eigentlich nicht besonders viel, was man sozusagen erobern kann. Ganz am Anfang hat der Paul ja mal gesagt, man würde jetzt Afghanistan wohl in einen Parkplatz verwandeln oder so. Das ist wohl so eine rhetorische Rede, wenn und die Amerikaner seit wir einen Namen drauf haben. Aber die Frage ist, was will man denn da parken? Vielleicht kannst du da auch noch mal was zu sagen. Wie realistisch ist dann jetzt dieses Afghanistan, diesen Krieg gegen von mir aus?
Interessant ist sich vorher vielleicht mal die NATO-Doktrin anzuschauen, und dann weißt du auch, was die anderen... Genau, dann hast du auch eine vage Ahnung davon, was die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika tatsächlich gewinnen wollen. Nämlich Einfluss. Die NATO, die ja doch von den USA dominiert wird, hat sich als neue Doktrin nach dem Fall der Mauer oder nach dem Ende des Kalten Krieges gesetzt, ihren Einfluss in Asien im Mittleren Osten binnen zehn Jahren auszubauen. Und binnen 20 Jahren im Übrigen in China. Also, wer weiß, was da noch passiert, obwohl die sprechen ja jetzt auch schon miteinander. Und dann hast du auch relativ schnell zumindest eine Ahnung, was sie da überhaupt gewinnen wollen. Beiden Gegner haben sie da nicht.
Nee, also die Taliban sind ja kein militärischer Gegner für Amerika. Und Herrn Bin Laden zu holen, wäre eigentlich eine Polizeiauferbe oder eine CAA-Aktion. Das ist ja auch so nicht bombenschmeißen. Das ist an sich, ja.
Sicher hat ja auch, wie heißt dieser Osloer Friedensforscher, der sagte, man müsste jetzt mal ganz schnell von dieser Kriegsrhetorik wieder auf eine Verbrechensrhetorik runterschalten, denn es ist ein Verbrechen verübt worden in den USA, in New York und nicht ein kriegerischer Akt.
Ja, könnte man trotzdem schon so sehen.
Also ich meine, es hat ihm ja auch niemand den Krieg erklärt, also den USA.
Nee, bin Laden hat den Krieg schon, der hat ja einen Heiligen Jihad, also den Jihad, den Heiligen Krieg gegen Amerika ausgerufen.
Der aber doch, wenn ich den Koran richtig interpretiere, ausschließlich in dem Land stattfinden darf, das angegriffen wird.
Nee, pass auf, jetzt, diese Leute fangen eine Neuinterpretation des Begriffs Jihad an. Also das fällt alle Medien zum Beispiel und auch diese ganzen Islam-Experten haben anscheinend die Interviews von denen nicht gelesen. Also das ist eine theologische Grundsatzfrage, die diese Leute jetzt stellen. Also jetzt bin Laden und seine Anhänger, diese Al-Qaeda und die Taliban, dass nur der ein rechtgläubiger Muslim ist, der den Jihad, und zwar den äußeren, gibt der mal, dass du mit dir selber im Kampf stehst für das Gute, also den Böse in dir besiegst und dich an die Gebote hältst und und und, den äußeren Jihad als muslimische Pflicht anerkennst. Ja, also du hast, die Muslime haben fünf Pflichten, also du musst fünfmal am Tag beten, einmal im Leben nach Mecca, denen die Fastenzeit einhalten, Almhosen geben für die Armen usw. Sie wollen, dass Jihad führen zu den Grundpflichten des Islam gehört. Das ist eine theologische Auseinandersetzung innerhalb des Islams, die sie anstrengen. Also der hat ja auch die Aktion gemacht für den Islam, für die Muslime der Welt und nicht um den Westen. Die Reaktion des Westens interessiert die herzlich wenig. Davon muss man mal aussehen. Also das ist dem vollkommen wurscht, was die ja alle erzählen.
Was interessiert ihn dann? Also was bezweckt er wirklich?
Die Leute zeichnen, dass eine Handvoll entschlossener Leute, die bereit sind, ihr Leben zu opfern, die größte Maschinerie der Welt, einen derartigen Schlag versetzen können. Das heißt also, seht her, wenn ihr den Heiligen Krieg führt, er ist gewinnbar. Wir können einfach mit einer Handvoll Leute, können wir denen so ein Ding reinsammeln, dass die wirklich im Quadrat springen. Das wird ja über den Rahmen bisheriger terroristischer Aktionen raus. Also bisher haben Leute irgendeinen Staatspräsidenten erschossen, eine Bombe gebastelt oder irgendwo. Hier ist ja eine absolut neue Dimension erreicht worden.
Wird das in der arabischen Welt anerkannt? Also erkennt die arabische Welt an und sagt, die arabische Welt ist eine...
Die islamische Welt ist ja nicht nur Arabien, also Indonesien, in Philippinen, die sitzen ja nun in China, die gibt es überall, die Judenleute.
Erkennen die das an und sagen, okay, das ist eine Art und Weise der Auseinandersetzung, so schwachsinnig sie vielleicht sein mag, das ist eine Art und Weise dieser theologischen Auseinandersetzung und wir nehmen auch das ernst oder...
Das ist die Frage. Da drüber erfährt man ja nichts. Also wir haben jetzt hier auch so ein paar auf dieses Website so ein paar von der Muslim Brotherhood und so Websites gesetzt, damit man mal nachsehen kann, soweit die denn englisch erhältlich sind, wie weit jetzt diese Diskussion läuft. Also letztendlich haben die innerhalb des Islams eine Diskussion angefangen damit. Also für sie ist Afghanistan ein Sprungbrett zum Heiligen Krieg gegen alles, was westlich ist.
Wie ernst zu nehmen ist denn dann, wenn irgendein islamisches Land sagt, ok, wir bekämpfen den Terror mit?
Das ist die Regierung dieses Landes. Heißt das auch, dass die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung den Kurs billigt? Das ist ja die Frage. Also er setzt ja darauf, dass immer mehr junge frustrierte Muslims in der Welt, die keine Arbeit haben, die keine Chancen sehen, und den Westen als Verursacher begreifen, ihrer materiellen Krisen oder ihrer Krise schlechthin in der sich befinden und dass die jetzt auf seine Linie einschwenken.
Was zumindest in den westlichen Gesellschaften schon funktioniert. Viele Menschen in den westlichen Gesellschaften begreifen sich selbst als Verursacher des Elends in diesen Ländern.
Das erste Mal, dass die Diskussion ernsthafter geführt wird. Ernsthafter wie nach Genoa. Nach Genoa waren es nur ein paar Leute, die üblichen Intellektuellen, die gesagt haben, wir müssen mal drüber nachdenken. Nach dem Ding fängt eine andere Diskussion an. Plötzlich soll wieder mehr Entwicklungshilfe gezahlt werden. Zum Beispiel, es gibt ja auch Aspekte, die war ja immer weiter runtergefahren. Und plötzlich sagen sie, wir müssen mehr zahlen. Plötzlich begreift doch jeder, wir sind reich nicht durch unsere Hände Arbeit, sondern weißt du, wer diese ganzen Länder die Rotstoffe ausbeuten und ihnen nicht den Preis zahlen, den sie eigentlich dafür kriegen müssten.
Wir schweifen an dieser Stelle ab. Wir hatten eben aufgerufen, anzurufen unter 0331 77 97 110. Die Frage stellt, ob ihr euch ausreichend informiert fühlt. Ich gehe einfach mal ans Telefon, wenn es den Herrschaften recht ist. Namen Karsten, du fühlst dich ausreichend informiert?
Nein, sonst würde ich ja nicht anrufen.
Es könnte doch sein, dass du sagst, ich bin toll informiert. Woran mangelt es dir?
Wenn ich mich bemühe, dann kann ich es ab und zu mal schaffen, eine gute Information zu kriegen. Aber die entscheidende Information kriege ich natürlich nicht.
Was ist die entscheidende Information?
Zum Beispiel die Beweise, dass es dieser schlimme Binna an war.
Die gibt es ja nicht, sonst hätten sie sie ja offengelegt.
Sie haben doch gesagt, sie haben Beweise, aber sie dürfen es nicht erzählen, weil dann das ganze Geheimdienstkonzept dem Bach runtergegangen wäre. Oder gehen würde. Sie haben ja irgendwas von Beweisen erzählt, aber die nicht veröffentlicht, aus dem Grund. Die Medien akzeptieren das jetzt alles. Sie schlucken es runter und sagen, klar, kann man sich vorstellen, dass sie das nicht offen sagen dürfen. Also war das.
Tun sie das? Schlucken wir das runter? Ich verstehe mich jetzt mal als die Medien, denn ich arbeite bei einem offiziellen Medium, beim öffentlich-rechtlichen deutschen Turnrundfunk. Wir schlucken das nicht. Ich habe da bestimmt auch eine Meinung dazu.
Aber durchaus wird es ja auch veröffentlicht in der Hinsicht. Bitte? Es wird ja auch durchaus veröffentlicht in der Hinsicht.
In welcher Hinsicht wird was veröffentlicht?
Na ja, die Beweise sind da. Bin Laden war es.
Wo sind die eigentlich jetzt mal? Wirklich eine Frage.
Die Beweise?
Entweder gibt es keine. Entweder gibt es keine? Der hat den bezahlt und der hat das gemacht, habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Ich habe das auch noch nie gesehen. Da hat ja noch der Anrufer Recht. Ja klar, aber schlucken wir es? Ich weiß nicht, ob wir es schlucken.
Ja, aber redet doch niemand mehr drüber.
Was wir machen, ist, wir berichten über das, was vor sich geht. So, und das ist dann zunächst mal die reine Berichterstattung, was darüber hinaus passiert. Kommentare, wie zum Beispiel Kommentare hier im Blue Moon abgegeben werden können, das ist ja auch wieder ein ganz anderes Blatt Papier.
Ja, aber ich denke, das gehört auch ein bisschen dazu, zu der Aufgabe der Medien. So, zum Beispiel könnte man, wenn man so ein kritischer Zeitgeist ist, dann könnte man sich auch fragen, also könnte man die Vermutung aufstellen, die meiner Meinung nach am nächsten Blick, dass irgendein Geheimnis gewusst hat, was da passiert, also kurz davor oder und ja.
Das finde ich ein bisschen gewagt, die These. Also wenn die Geheimnisse das gewusst hätte, dann irgendwie der Frage des, das Gebäude Nummer 1 von New York kaputt machen zu lassen, das finde ich so ein bisschen und vor allem noch 6000 Leute drin, irgendwie, ne?
Ja, naja, ich sage mal so, ich persönlich gehe davon aus, dass so etwas passieren kann, dass die da irgendwie so was ins Kalkül ziehen und dann mitmachen. Aber natürlich ist es gewagt, so was zu sagen. Aber es wird noch nicht an den Gedanken gespielt.
Wie wäre denn Carsten, mal angenommen, wir nehmen diesen Gedanken jetzt, also die Geheimdienste haben es gewusst, stellen wir einfach diesen Gedanken in den Raum. Der amerikanische Geheimdienst, also die CIA, hat gewusst, dass das passieren wird und hat es billigend in Kauf genommen, um den amerikanischen Einfluss im Nahen Osten erhöhen zu können. Wie wäre denn deiner Meinung nach der Adäquator, also der angemessene Umgang der Medien, mit diesem Gedanken, über eine solche Sendung wie den Blumun hinausgehend?
Ja, man kann Vermutung äußern und dadurch kann man die in Erklärungsnot bringen. Also sie müssten sich zumindest rechtfertigen und...
Dann sagt die CIA, nö wussten wir nicht.
Ja, aber da müssten sie es auf alle Fälle sagen und die Leute würden nicht... Es geht ja eigentlich auch jetzt mehr um innenpolitische Sachen in den USA, um die Verschärfung irgendwelcher Sicherheitsgesetze und so. Und dann wäre es halt schwerer, diese innenpolitischen Sachen durchzusetzen, auch hier in Deutschland, weil dann sozusagen ein bisschen kritischer damit umgegangen wird und dann die Leute nicht so einfach sagen, ja, okay, das ist das. Und das mit dem Anthrax, das ist jetzt auch dieselbe Schiene und es waren dieselben Leute, dieselbe Gruppe und so. Und dann sollte man einfach in den Kommentaren auch vor allen Dingen damit spielen, also was alles möglich wäre und nicht so Scheuklappen aufhaben und so die PC-Sache irgendwie wahren wollen.
Es ist schwierig, weil mein Job ist ja eigentlich, dass ich mich bemühe, zumindest bemühe, die Realität abzubilden. Das ist ja eigentlich meine Hauptaufgabe, was darüber hinaus geht. Und da sind wir dann eben mit so einer Annahme, die CIA hätte davon wissen können oder hat davon gewusst, da begeben wir uns in einen spekulativen Bereich, das nennt man dann, glaube ich, Agitation auch. Also was man sicherlich machen kann und was meines Erachtens auch passiert, leider nicht laut genug, bzw. gucken die Leute nicht die richtigen Sendungen wahrscheinlich auch im Fernsehen. Man könnte die Bundesregierung zum Beispiel darum bitten, doch erstmal Beweise vorzulegen, wenn in unserem Namen Krieg geführt wird. Also ich wüsste ganz gerne, warum in meinem Namen Krieg geführt wird. Das ist sicherlich legitim, dass Medien das machen, aber das tun sie auch. Das heißt, Fragen stellen. Also Fragen stellen können wir, aber wir können schlechthin die nun Mutmaßungen abgeben und die im Raum stehen lassen.
Ja, das habe ich ja gesagt, sollte man sich hüten vor irgendwelchen Sachen, die man eigentlich so weit hergeholt hat. Aber man kann Fragen stellen und das wird häufig nicht gemacht. Das meinte ich jetzt.
Welchen Rahmen würdest du dir dafür wünschen? Also ich meine, das wird auch gleich stattfinden, wir haben jetzt gleich Nachrichten hier, die ja tatsächlich nur Abbild dessen sind, was in der Welt passiert, beziehungsweise gefiltertes und sortiertes Abbild dessen. Also welchen Rahmen würdest du dir wünschen, um die andere Sichtweise zu Wort kommen zu lassen?
So was wie Blue Moon oder irgendwelche Talkshows oder so. Bei Talkshows kommen ja auch manchmal Leute, die ein bisschen kritischere Sachen rausgucken lassen. Und man merkt dann sozusagen, wie der Moderator darauf reagiert und so. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass manche Sachen, zum Beispiel von diesen Schalatur irgendwie, der wurde bei manchen Talkshows irgendwie regelrecht abgewirkt. Oder sozusagen wurde ihm über den Mund gefahren und dann das Thema weggelenkt oder ein anderer gefragt zu irgendeiner Sache.
Worauf führst du das zurück?
Na ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hat der Moderator dann dort irgendwie ein paar Präferenzen gehabt, die er zu erfüllen hatte und wusste nicht so richtig, wie weiter jetzt geht dieser Schalatur. Und hat sozusagen quasi so eine Schere ein bisschen im Kopf gehabt, der Moderator. Und dementsprechend diese Talkshow so gelenkt.
Das mag dich vielleicht interessieren, dass man bestimmte Sendungen nur moderieren darf, wenn man eine bestimmte politische Richtung auch konsequent verfolgt und das richtige Parteibuch hat. In diesem Sinne entlasse ich dich Carsten, wir müssen nämlich Nachrichten machen. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ja, wobei, also eine kleine Bemerkung würde ich mir ja gerne erlauben. Zum Beispiel, was ich mir wünschen würde, wenn es jetzt tatsächlich darum geht, dass hier Nachrichten verlesen werden, dann würde ich keinen Sport hören. Das hat Sport mit Nachrichten zu tun. Ganz im Ernst.
Auch das ist eine religiöse Diskussion.
Es gibt Leute, für die hat Sport den Nachrichtenwert eines Tratschgesprächs im Treppenhaus. Es gibt aber auch Leute, für die hat es einen wesentlich größeren Nachrichtenwert. Das erkennst du zum Beispiel daran, dass der Innenminister dieses Landes sich bemüssigt fühlt, sich darüber zu äußern, wie denn die Nationalmannschaft gespielt hat, beziehungsweise nicht gespielt hat.
Der hat nach den bescheidenen Kriterien meines Wertesystems ohnehin irgendwie an der Waffe.
Darum kümmern wir uns gleich. Das ist ein Wort. Ich bügel dich jetzt einfach mal ab und nach den Nachrichten reden wir weiter. Patrick und Thorsten, ihr bleibt bitte dran. Ihr dürft nämlich gleich auch noch mit uns sprechen.
Dann 101, 5.
23.33 Uhr. Fritz, Kurzinfo. Nachts etwas Regen, 9 bis 5 Grad morgen, dann Wolkenreich bei 12 bis 15 Grad. Und jetzt schon die Meldung mit Bastian Berner.
Die Ingangsgesetz der Entwaffnung der nordirischen Untergrundorganisation IAA hat den Friedensprozess neu belebt. Die britische Regierung kündigte die Auflösung von vier Militärstützpunkten an. Auch die Reformen der bisher protestantisch dominierten Polizei von Nordirland sollen nun zügig umgesetzt werden. Die USA wollen ihre Angriffe auf Afghanistan auch im bevorstehenden Winter fortsetzen. Außenminister Paul erklärte, es gehe nicht um Zeitlimits, sondern darum, die gesteckten Ziele zu erreichen. Er wies zugleich Forderungen zurück, nachdem die Angriffe während des Fastenmonats Ramadan eingestellt werden sollten. Das Ausmaß des Feuers im Schweizer Gotthardtunnel ist weiterhin unklar. Die Behörden rechnen bis zu 20 Toten, ein direkter Zugang zum Brandherd war wegen der extremen Hitze bis zum Abend noch nicht möglich. Und jetzt zum Sport in der Fußball Champions League. Ja, der eben besprochene Sport. Zum Sport in der Fußball Champions League setzte sich am Abend Borussia Dortmund gegen Dynamo Kiew mit 1 zu 0 durch. Damit bewahrte sich das Team von Trainer Samer seine Chance auf die Zwischenrunde. Ausgeschieden ist dagegen Schalke 04, der deutsche Vizemeister, unterlag bei Panathinaikos Athen mit 0 zu 2. Und nochmal der Sport. Der deutsche Basketballmeister Al-Barbelin bleibt auf internationalem Parkett siedlos. Am 3. Spieltag der Euroleague unterlagen die Berliner bei FS Istanbul mit 68 zu 72. Nach der 3. Niederlage in Folge sind die Chancen der Albatros auf das Erreichen der Zwischenrunde auf ein Minimum gesunken. Scherverkehr auf Fritz A100-Stadtring zwischen Dreieck-Tempelhof und Brizadam bis Ende des Monatssperrung der linken Spuren in Richtung Treptow. Kreuzberg an der Kreuzung Friedrich- und Kochstraße bis Ende des Monats Behinderung wegen Bauarbeiten. Stadtverkehr Potsdam Breite Straße zwischen Schopenhauer Straße und Langerbrücke bis Mitte Dezember Behinderung in beiden Richtungen. Das Linksabbiegen in die Dortowstraße ist nicht möglich.
Nachrichten, Verkehr und Sport mit Bastian Dörner. Vielen Dank, 5,512.
Nur 5 von 20 Bands, die Fritz zusammen mit dem Uncle Sallys Magazin auf Berlin Machtschule Teil 3 präsentiert. Und die werden live dabei sein, bei der Record-Release-Party am 30. Oktober im Columbia Fritz. Es kluckt zum Radio. Berlin Machtschule Teil 3, New Rock und New Punk am 30. Oktober. Und im Radio, Fritz.
Bin gespannt, ihr da so in habt Chaosradio 66 auf Fritz. Gegenpäpste in Krisenzeiten ist unser Thema. Nein, gegen Öffentlichkeit.
Die Frage lautete, fühlt ihr euch eigentlich ausreichend informiert oder würdet ihr euch andere Informationen und wenn ja, welcher Art von Informationen wünschen? Guten Abend, Patrick.
Ja, hallo. Reicht es dir, was an Informationen kommt?
Oder ist es dir zu wenig?
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Also es ist so, dass man kriegt halt irgendwie, meistens ist es ja aus dem Fernsehen oder aus dem Radio, was man an öffentlichen Informationen hat. Kriegt man halt vermittelt, dass die Taliban einfach böse sind, ja. Und das schlägt sich so nieder, dass zum Beispiel auf ARD wurde, oder ZDF, ich weiß jetzt nicht, welches Programm es war, wurde halt so eine Dokumentar- wie sagt man aber, Serie veranstaltet, wo man dann gezeigt hat, wie halt auch die Taliban irgendwelche Leute exekutieren öffentlich.
Ach, es kursiert derzeit ein Dokumentarfilm, der ist glaube ich 45 Minuten lang von einer Frau, selber Afghanin, die mit versteckter Kamera durchs Land gereist ist. Das meinst du?
Ja, den meine ich ja. Und das sage ich mir halt so, okay, die bringen dort auch Leute um, die exekutieren Leute, weil sie irgendwie gegen ein Gesetz verstoßen haben. Aber ich meine, dasselbe gibt es ja in Amerika auch. Ich meine, es gibt auch eine Todesstrafe.
Und das möchtest du miteinander aufwiegen? Also, dass die Taliban öffentliche Hinrichtungen in einem mit EU-Geldern, nee, mit UN-Geldern geförderten Fußballstadion durchführen, möchtest du damit vergleichen, dass in den USA wenigstens auf Grundlage der Gesetze...
Ja, da werden auch die todigen Leute umgebracht. Also ich meine, ich bin grundsätzlich gegen die Todesstrafe, das ist halt meine Sache. Und die Taliban, die bringen halt aus irgendwelchen religiösen Gründen Leute um. Und die Amerikaner bringen dann Leute um unter rechtsstaatlichen, unter Anführungsstrichen, Voraussetzungen.
Gut, darüber hinaus ist es auch so, dass die USA Menschen umbringen aufgrund eines, aufgrund des Spruches eines mehr oder minder unabhängigen Gerichtes, dass sie auf die Gesetze in den USA stützt. Und die Taliban bringen Leute um, die sich gegen Menschenrechtsverletzung auflehnen, indem sie zum Beispiel einen Schleier nicht tragen. Also da finde ich schon einen himmelweiten Unterschied.
Ja, das stimmt. So gesehen ja.
Also ich meine, wenn ich die Menschenrechtsverletzung als geltendes Recht definiere und dann sage jeder, der vielleicht Menschenrechte wahrnehmen möchte, wird erschossen?
Weil letztendlich, was dahinter steht, ist ja Folgendes, dass man eigentlich keine Leute umbringen darf.
Das ist richtig.
Weil das darf eigentlich kein Mensch. Also ich meine, es ist egal, unter welchen jetzt Gesetzgebungen das stattfindet, öffentlich Leute umzubringen. Und das ist ja auch in Amerika der Fall, dass solche Hinrichtungen halt irgendwie öffentlich sind. Und dass man das auf dem Bildschirm oder ich glaube sogar das Internet verfolgen kann. Das heißt sich einfach für schlecht. Und das ist in Amerika wie im Taiwan dasselbe.
Welchen Umgang der bundesdeutschen Medien würdest du dir wünschen? Also es gibt ja ohnehin zwei unterschiedliche Umgangsweisen der Medien mit Themen. Also es ist einmal das öffentlich-rechtliche, die ja doch, würde ich jetzt mal behaupten, auch...
Die kann man ja glaube ich auch auf RTL oder so, oder?
Nee, das ist eine Arte, ich glaube eine Arte-Produktion gewesen.
Aber es wird eine BBC-Produktion gewesen. Und die Hinrichtungen sind ja interessant von Frauen heimlich gedreht worden. Das sind die Rawa-Frauen, die mit Kameras da nach Afghanistan reingehen. Und das heimliche Film, die würden dafür erschossen, wenn sie erwischt werden. Also diese Aufnahmen sind schon von einer independenten Gruppe erstellt worden, um überhaupt die Weltöffentlichkeit auf die Zustände aufmerksam zu machen.
Aber das Schöne ist ja dort, dass die Frauen das Recht haben, sich grundsätzlich zu verschleiern. Deswegen kann man diese Frauen einfach gar nicht ausfindig machen. Weil diese Frauen dann irgendwie ohnehin verschleiert rumlaufen in der Öffentlichkeit. Also selbst wenn die jetzt zum Beispiel gegen den Taliban protestieren. Und da gibt es ja wirklich Frauen in der Öffentlichkeit, die im Fernsehen sich stark machen, die zeigen ihr Gesicht. Das ist denen scheißegal, weil die haben den Schleier in der Öffentlichkeit. Und wie soll man diese Frauen dingfest machen?
Wenn ich da auch noch mal kurz einschreiten darf, sie haben nicht nur das Recht, sich zu verschleiern, sie haben die verdammte Pflicht, sich zu verschleiern.
Und wenn sie das nicht machen...
Ja, das ist doch für die Frauen gut, weil die... Nee, also in dem Sinn...
Du meinst, es ist spezifisch für Frauen von Rabat, die sich da irgendwie...
Natürlich ist es eine Beschränkung der Rechte von den Frauen. Das finde ich natürlich auch scheiße. Aber die haben dadurch die Möglichkeit, sich wirklich stark zu machen. Und das...
Du meinst, das ist ein besseres Tarmnetz? Ja, das ist ein besseres Tarmnetz.
Ja, sozusagen. Das ist die Verschlüsselung, die man da hat.
Ja gut, aber da kannst du getarnt sein, wie du willst, und nicht entdeckt werden, wie du willst. Wenn dein vordringliches Problem ist, was zu fressen zu kriegen, weil du nämlich nicht arbeiten darfst und betteln musst, dann ist es mit der Stärke irgendwie nicht mehr weit her.
Also ich finde es ja auch nicht gut, dass die Frauen da verschleidet rumlaufen müssen. Ja, ich hatte noch zwei Fragen. Und zwar das eine war mit der Webcam unter Fritz.
Haltet ihr euch da bedeckt oder?
Ja, wir scheuen Öffentlichkeit. Nein, wir haben das Kabel gebraucht. Es tut mir leid.
Ja, weil da kommt immer nur dasselbe Bild. Und dann hatte ich nochmal eine Frage, weil mich das persönlich interessiert. Da gibt es ja eine Mailingliste und da wurde ein Link geschickt von einer Erklärung vom CCC. Und da ist halt ein Schili Terror 1 PDF zur Verfügung. Ich wollte wissen, wo ihr das her habt.
Oh, das ist irgendwie aufgetaucht. Also das Problem ist ja in der Tat nicht nur, dass Herr Schili und das Innenministerium sich gerade in mittlerweile zwei bis drei Dokumenten, nicht nur also Vorschläge, das ist ja nur ein Vorschlagspapier, es gibt auch ein Gesetzespapier, das sind 135 Seiten ausdenkt, sondern dass sie das im Verborgenen tun. Wir sagen, diese Dokumente sind offiziell nie öffentlich gemacht worden. Sie sind offenbar zwischen SPD und Grüne und einigen anderen Abgeordneten, aber selbst die Abgeordneten der Grünen, die ich kenne, haben mir also gesagt, das können sie mir nicht geben, sonst erfahren sie gar nichts mehr. Und irgendwie sind diese Dokumente dann aufgetaucht. Keine Ahnung, irgendwie waren die auf einmal da. Ich habe gerade meine Mail gecheckt, deswegen geht die Webcam übrigens nicht. Ich habe gerade noch ein anderes Dokument bekommen, das ist da auch gleich verlinkt. Manchmal gibt es da draußen noch anständige Menschen, die vielleicht merkwürdige Arbeitsplätze haben, aber sich dann doch denken, dass Demokratie eine gute Idee ist und nicht konspiratives Aussehen.
Aber die sitzen nicht im Bundestag.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die sitzen. Ich kriege hier so komische Mails, ich weiß da gar nicht, wie mein Header liest.
Abschließen wollte ich noch mal kurz eine Sache sagen. Ich finde, die Berichterstattung der Zeitung, ich meine, ich bin in Hannover und deswegen lese ich ab und zu mal die Hats. Und über das Fernsehen, die ist wirklich gottenschlecht. Man wird einfach gar nicht aufgeklärt, was die nun wirklich da denken, was die Religion ausmacht. Und meistens, wenn man da irgendwie Sympathie über das Fernsehen gewinnen will, da habe ich gestern irgendwie so einen Bericht gesehen, der war einfach nur, weil es da eine Liebe zwischen einer Muslimin und einem Katholiken gab.
Hast du da wieder Privatfernsehen oder Brisant geguckt oder sowas?
Nee, Privatfernsehen habe ich nicht. Ich habe einfach nur die normalen Kanäle, die es da gibt. Und das finde ich halt verdammt erschreckend, weil das einfach überhaupt nicht objektiv ist und einfach mal nicht gesagt wird, was wirklich da bei den Muslimen im Koran verankert steht. Und es steht ja irgendwie auch an keiner Stelle im Koran, dass man verschleiert sein muss.
Es steht schon drin, dass Frauen ihre Reize zu bedecken haben.
Ja, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass die rumlaufen müssen wie die Mumien.
Das ist richtig. Also es ist dann sicherlich wieder Auslegungssache. Also das müsste dann ein Gelehrter auf dem Wege der Scharia erläutern.
Das steht ja alles irgendwie alles nicht drin und letztendlich haben die auch den gleichen Grundkonsens wie Christen, denke ich mal, dass man Leute nicht töten soll. Und da wird einfach nicht objektiv darüber berichtet, dass das im Koran nicht drin steht, dass man einfach mal irgendwelche Attentate verüben soll. Und vor allen Dingen, das lernt man ja sowieso auch gar nicht in der Schule irgendwie.
Was ganz interessant an dieser Stelle ist, ich habe vor 14 Tagen, oder es ist 4 Wochen her, eine Sendung gemacht, da hatte ich einen Imam zu Gast, der hat uns den Islam erklärt. Daraufhin haben sich Menschen beschwert und sagten, das wäre ja völlig einseitig, so könnte das ja nicht gehen.
Ja, also...
Wenn man...
Und was denn überhaupt ein Imam wäre, genau, also so, da könnte ja jeder kommen.
Wenn man in einem Religionsunterricht erklärt kriegt, was die Juden bedeuten, was die Leute aus dem Islam und die Muslime und die Katholiken und die Evangelen bedeuten, dann hätte man da wenigstens schon mal so ein bisschen so ein Verständnis dafür.
Das ist richtig, das Problem könnte sein, also das bitte ich jetzt auch als Privatmeinung, also in die Ablage Privatmeinung zu stecken, dass der Islam die ethisch wahrscheinlich etwas weniger zu beanstande Religion ist als das Christentum. Und darum, dass Christentum sicherlich auch ein Problem damit hat, über den Islam zu berichten, zumindest objektiv und sachlich über den Islam zu berichten.
Das ist mir eigentlich egal, weil ich denke so so nicht religiös, aber letztendlich will ich sowas halt in meiner Erziehung mit drin haben, beziehungsweise in meiner Bildung, um zu wissen, ja der denkt wahrscheinlich so.
Das ist eigentlich was, was man erwarten könnte vom Religionsunterricht, aber der Religionsunterricht kümmert sich ja am liebsten um sich selbst und nicht um andere Religionen. Das ist ja zumindest eine Erfahrung, die ich gemacht habe in meiner Zeit.
Das ist ja auch Religionsunterricht, ne? Der ist ja auch staatsvertraglich geregelt hier.
Ja gut, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass ich nicht auch mal über meinen Tellerrand rausgucken kann. Und das haben zumindest meine Religionslehrer nie auf die Reihe bekommen. Dazu hatten die irgendwie zu viel Angst oder zu wenig Ahnung. Ich danke für deinen Anruf, Patrick. So, jetzt nehmen wir noch den Thorsten. Thorsten? Ey, du bist noch da, das ist gut. Danke fürs Warten. Thorsten? Ja, sag doch auch was.
Ja, er sagt ja jede Menge hier. Bin ich jetzt auf Sendung, oder?
Ja, du bist auf Sendung, Thorsten.
Aber ich krieg keine Frage und kein Feedback.
Wie, du kriegst keine Frage und kein Feedback?
Ja, kommt ja nix hier.
Willst du jetzt eine Frage hören?
Sollen wir dir eine Frage stellen, oder was?
Eine Frage stellen? Nein, ihr sollt mir keine Frage stellen. Ich wollte ja wissen, ob ich jetzt hier jetzt gar bin. Es geht eigentlich bloß darum, halt so, äh, worum geht's an sich? Ja, hier bei euch am Anfang der Sendung halt so. Äh, viele Sachen sind mir aufgefallen, die ziemlich oft auf Topic gelandet sind eigentlich so. Also, äh, fühle ich mich irgendwie, hm.
Thorsten, fühlst du dich überhaupt irgendwie? Also wollen wir erstmal noch eine kleine Musik machen, du überlegst dir, wie du dich fühlst, und dann sprechen wir nochmal miteinander.
Was hälst du davon?
Schlecht informiert, schlecht informiert fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht. Ich fühle mich einfach bloß, äh, desinformiert. Das, das dingt altweilig.
Unterstellst du willentliche Desinformation?
Willentlich nicht, auf keinen Fall, kann man nicht sagen. Es ist eben, äh, absolut, äh, hm, es ist so ein, so ein, so ein Bedürfnis von allen möglichen Fronten und von allen möglichen Leuten her, äh, ihren Quark dazu zu geben, halt so. Ich will jetzt auch nicht hier, äh, äh, bei irgendjemandem auf den Schlips treten oder so, aber auf jeden Fall habe ich das Gefühl, dass alle irgendwas dazu sagen wollen, aber nichts richtig dazu sagen können. Ist so meine Meinung.
Es ist ja auch tatsächlich so. Ich meine, das lässt sich am Fernsehen, glaube ich, am besten ablesen. Sie müssen Bilder produzieren. Also Fernsehen lebt davon, dass Bilder gesendet werden. Also werden irgendwelche Bilder gesendet, deren Wahrheitsgehalt teilweise noch nicht mal überprüft wird. Ich erinnere da an die jubelnde Palästinenser kurz nach den Anschlägen.
Ja, das ist eine interessante Geschichte gewesen.
Das ist sicherlich richtig.
Also halber Fake und halbe Wahrheit.
Hast du das flächendeckend? Oder sagst du, es gibt bestimmte Nachrichtenformate oder Nachrichtensituationen, in denen du nicht das Gefühl hast, gerade desinformiert zu werden, sei es willendlich oder unwillendlich?
Nein, nur speziell in diesem Fall, weil das ist jetzt, gerade durch diese ganze Militärwierung und durch diesen ganzen Zwang, der aus Amerika heraus schwappt, und auch durch Deutschland vereinnahmt, also deutsche Politiker will ich mal speziell sagen. Ich will jetzt keinen beim Namen nennen. Man kennt hier einen speziell, der momentan ziemlich trampelig geraten ist dabei. Auf jeden Fall ganz schön krass rüberkommt die ganze Geschichte. Also wenn dann von uneingeschränkter Zustimmung zu solchen militärischen Aktionen und so weiter geraten wird und dass man nicht mehr seine Meinung sagen darf und so weiter, dann wird das schon...
Die ersten zwei Wochen war die Gedankenpolizei extrem aktiv.
Ja, nicht nur. Er ist ja noch am Wirbeln und macht ja auch so sein Ding. Gerade in Deutschland geht es ja mehr in Richtung Big Brother.
Das war ja auch eine wildliche Selbstentscheidung der deutschen Bundesregierung, das zu machen. Das ist ja nicht rübergeschwappt wie so eine...
Nee, es ist sogar so, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, dann war es sogar Gerhard Schröder, also unser Bundeskanzler selbst, der die Kruzpe besessen hat, kurz nach den Anschlägen zu sagen, das war ein Anschlag auf die gesamte freie Welt. Und damit hat dieser Mann mir zumindest in den Arsch getreten.
Das war auch so ein Ding, was ich in den Foren und so weiter gelesen habe, im Internet, was mir voll bitter aufgestoßen hat. Für wen spricht der Mensch?
Na, der spricht für dich, der spricht für mich und der spricht für alle, die hier sitzen. Zumindest sagt er das, denn wir haben ihn legitimiert.
Er spricht für alle eigentlich, als derjenige, der uns vertritt. Es ist ja nicht nur er, es ist auch Schili und so weiter, die dann irgendwelche Sachen schmieden. Gut, es ist ein anderes Feld wieder, eine andere Geschichte, aber die dem CCC auch...
Nicht wirklich eine andere Geschichte. Geht da eben Hand in Hand. Aber die einzige Möglichkeit, die wir da haben, wäre, diese Regierung abzuwählen bei der nächsten Wahl.
Mit dem Abwählen, das ist ja echt eine Geschichte, oder?
Wenn du eine Alternative hast, ist das mit dem Anfragen...
Wenn du eine Alternative hast, ja.
Dann können wir uns jetzt mal über die Sinnhaftigkeit...
Als Innenminister wird es ja auch nicht besser.
Dann können wir uns jetzt mal über die Sinnhaftigkeit der parlamentarischen Demokratie unterhalten. Entschuldige, Thorsten, bitte?
Böse Alternativen bieten sich gerade in Hamburg, die noch viel schlimmer sind als das, was schon da ist. Das ist da jetzt momentan so ein Feld, wo... Schili ohne Y so angewiesen werden, wo die ganz böse Dinge hervorbringen können.
Das ist allerdings richtig. Was würdest du dir denn wünschen? Was würdest du dir von einem öffentlich-rechtlichen Radio wünschen, das es macht, damit du dich nicht desinformiert fühlst?
Ja, was würde ich mir wünschen? Momentan, ich will jetzt keinen öffentlich-rechtlichen oder überhaupt keinen Radio, überhaupt keine Informationsanstalt, einen Vorwurf machen, dass sie irgendwelche Fehler machen. Weil können sie nicht. Sie wären ja nicht informiert.
Ja, ich könnte mich doch hinstellen und sagen, es tut mir leid, ich bin nicht in der Lage, jetzt eine Meldung abzuliefern, denn ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwas, was ich melden könnte, der Wahrheit entspräche.
Ja, ansatzweise haben das ja wohl schon Leute gemacht, und wurden dafür dann abgeworfen, oder? Ich weiß nicht, also... Ich meine, es gab schon so Fälle, oder?
Na ja, Wicart war so dämlich als öffentlich-rechtlicher Journalist, tatsächlich breitenwirksam.
Er hat einen Vergleich gezogen, der nicht von der Hand zu weisen ist. Der ist ja wohl wirklich nicht von der Hand zu weisen.
Sicherlich nicht von der Hand zu weisen, aber die Frage ist immer, geziemt es sich, für den Moderator der Tagesthemen einen solchen Standpunkt zu verteiden.
Er hat mich gerade gefragt, soll ich einen Beispiel nennen, zum Beispiel? Und wenn der das schon nicht darf, weil er schon einer der Leuchten ist in dieser Nachrichtenkultur, was sollen dann die ganzen kleinen Lichter machen?
Aber man bekommt ja durchaus mit, dass so der eine oder andere Korrespondent oder Korrespondentin, die da gerade aus der Region versuchen zu berichten, dass sie richtig abgegessen sind von der ganzen Sache.
Insbesondere wenn man mit den Korrespondenten außerhalb eines sozusagen On-Air-Seins spricht. Thorsten, ich danke für deinen Anruf. Das ist übrigens das Chaosradio Nummer 66 hier und wir reden über Gegenöffentlichkeit, zumindest versuchen wir es, über Gegenöffentlichkeit in Krisenzeiten zu reden. Ihr könnt auch weiter anrufen. 0331 77 97 1 1 0 Ich kriege immer noch Schriften in der Mail.
Da hast du gerade erwacht von Günther.
Ratz, nee, das ist nur so ein Spruch. Am Günther ist kein Telefon, also am Telefon kein Günther. 0331 77 97 110. Die Nummer um noch ungefähr eine Stunde hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz mitzureden. Gegenöffentlichkeit in Zeiten der Krise ist unser Thema und uns würde interessieren, ob ihr euch ausreichend informiert fühlt bzw. was eure Meinung zur Art und Weise der Information ist, die dieser Tage stattfindet in bundesdeutschen, öffentlich-rechtlichen wie privaten Medien. Guten Abend, Petra.
Ich habe jetzt zugehört intensiv und ich muss sagen, mir ist das konkret in diesem Zusammenhang mit diesen Ereignissen am 11. September so gegangen, dass die Informationen, die auch die öffentlich-rechtlichen gebracht haben, zu intensiv waren. Und zwar will ich das so erläutern. Es bleibt den Leuten keine Zeit nachzudenken, diese unerhörten Berichterstattung sich setzen zu lassen, sich eigene Gedanken zu machen. Denn immer, wenn man das Radio wieder anschaltet oder anstellt, oder es wird ja auch gewünscht, dass man es eigentlich nicht ausmacht, wurde informiert, manchmal auch krampfhaft informiert, dann hat man versucht, irgendwelche Leute, bekannte Freunde, die sich zufällig in New York aufgehalten haben, ein Apparat zu kriegen und deren persönliche Meinung zu übertragen und deren persönliche Empfindung, das hat doch schon wieder was voyeuristisches.
Darf ich?
Es war sicher gut gemeint, um zu informieren, wie sieht es denn vor Ort aus, aber das war unmittelbar in den ersten Stunden, Tagen unnötig. Das war völlig unnötig, denn die Leute, die ich gehört habe, die konnten ja selbst ihre Gefühle noch nicht sortieren.
Darf ich dir eine semantische Frage zwischendurch stellen? Du sagtest immer, wenn man das Radio angeschaltet hat, wurde man informiert. Empfindest du das wirklich als Information?
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich beziehe meine Information ausschließlich aus dem Radio, mal abgesehen von der Presse, die ein kleines bisschen hinterher hinken muss, aus zäschlichen Gründen. Und ich habe gezielt das Radio angeschaltet, um mich zu informieren. Das mache ich so. Ich wechsle auch nichts gegen Fritz, aber ich wechsle auch zwischen Deutschlandfunk. Ich habe mir eben gezielt dann den Deutschlandfunk angeschaltet, um mal eine Information, wenn ich da mal eine Stunde gehört habe, dann weiß ich was am Tag, während ich arbeite, kann ich nicht hören, am Tag so angefallen ist und kriege dann auch ein bisschen Informationen drum herum und paar Zusammenhänge oder man macht das mal über ein Inforadio, wobei ich aber sagen muss, ich habe ungefähr, ich nehme an, das war an der gleichen Woche, Dienstags ist das geschehen, am Donnerstag, glaube ich, hat der Washington-Bloom-Moon gemacht, am Donnerstagabend. Da war ich das erste Mal, also man ist ja auch bloß ein Mensch und nach solchen unerhörten Ereignissen, die auf der Welt noch nie da gewesen sind, bewegen ihn ja Gefühle, Gedanken und Sachen und man traut sich ja auch nicht wegen diesem, wie sagt man da, wegen diesem besonders schlimmen Ereignis, so einfache Gedanken zu äußern oder zuzulassen. Man ist ja betroffen.
Einfache Gedanken, welcher Art?
Ja, ich wusste schon, dass ich mich jetzt verkange. Ich habe jetzt kein Beispiel, aber ganz einfache Sachen. Wer ist der beladen? Man muss sich ja auch mal trauen zu sagen oder zuzugeben, dass man nicht gut informiert ist oder sowas. Und diese Fragen sind bei Wosch in diesem zugelassen worden und er hatte auch kompetente Gesprächspartner, die gut eingehen konnten auf die Fragen der jungen Hörer, die manchmal selbst überfordert waren mit solchen Fragen, weil man die zu dem Zeitpunkt natürlich nicht schlüssig beantworten konnte, weil man ja selber als Erwachsener oder als älterer Mensch mit sich zu tun hatte bei diesem unerhörten Ausmaß dieser Geschehnisse. Also ich muss sagen, aber die Intensität, das war sicher wohl gemeint, aber ich denke mir auch, die Öffentlichen, Rechtlichen lassen sich zuweilen in einen Wettbewerb drängen, naja, aus geschäftlichen Gründen, wirtschaftlichen Gründen oder mitzuhalten und damit...
Die lassen sich nicht nur bis Weilen drängen, sondern sie lassen sich ständig drängen. Sie stellen sich selber da rein, ja, das ist richtig.
Und das ist eigentlich schade drum, darunter leidet sachliche Information. Die reine Nachricht, also die Qualität der Nachricht, der Information, die leidet darunter, weil immer noch Zusatzinformationen geliefert werden, die dann nicht mehr diesen informatorischen Wert, diesen exemplarischen Wert haben.
Du bist einfach Puristin in der Hinsicht.
Bitte?
Du bist Puristin in der Hinsicht. Du willst einfach die pure, pure Nachricht haben, aber was ist denn die pure Nachricht?
Sie ist zumindest nicht wertend.
Ist sie das? Ja, es dürfte nicht gewertet werden.
Sollte sie nicht sein?
Sie müsste auch emotionslos sein.
Das Problem ist jetzt wieder, dass du natürlich als derjenige, der die Nachricht entgegennimmt, also die Nachricht hört, rezipiert sozusagen, nicht in der Lage bist zu beurteilen, ob die Nachricht die ganze Nachricht war oder nur die halbe Nachricht.
Und von daher kann man auch nicht sagen, dass die Nachricht objektiv ist.
Ja, da sind wir wieder bei dem Punkt, wo es dann auf dem Wahrheitsgehalt hinausläuft und den, den nie feststellen kannst, weil du die Quelle deiner Nachricht nicht kennst. Das ist dann aber, da müssen wir unterscheiden. Das ist dann, jetzt definieren wir in philosophischen Charakteren der Nachricht an sich. Und das andere ist die Art und Weise, wie ihr öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk anbietet. Also sicher, sicher muss man praktikable Lösungen suchen. Aber mir ist das ausgefallen, dass man sich da eben bei solchen besonderen Ereignissen eben leicht drängen lässt in so einem Wettbewerb. Wobei das nicht durchgängig so ist.
Man möchte immer der Erste sein, der irgendetwas gemeldet hat, dann freut man sich. Das stelle ich ja an mir selber auch fest.
Wahrscheinlich in der Natur des Journalismus an sich.
Offensichtlich, also stelle ich es sogar an mir fest. Und ich bin doch nicht mal ein richtiger Journalist, dass ich teilweise sage, ja, erster.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt andere Menschen auch so empfinden, aber ich, naja, ihr habt gefragt nach Nachrichten, fühlt ihr euch gut informiert. Es war eine Überinformation, die dann, die Quantität geht zulassen, die Qualität.
Aber das war ja eigentlich gar nicht so eine richtige Überinformation. Du hast vorhin auch selbst gesagt, irgendwie die Leute in den Fernsehanstalten und Radioanstalten, die konnten ja überhaupt nichts sagen, weil sie nichts wussten.
Die Magaziner, die so nachmittags laufen oder so, ich höre das dann im Auto, wenn ich nach Hause fahre oder so, die haben sich immer bemüßigt gefunden, immer zum Thema nach irgendjemanden, der aus einer anderen Ecke noch mal was sagen kann und der... Und immer wieder, das hängt den Leuten zum Hals raus, die drehen weg und die hören BB-Radio.
Petra, ich danke für deinen Anruf.
Wenn du auch mal irgendeine Musik brauchst.
Stimmt allerdings, ich danke dir für deinen Anruf, Petra. Aber was eben tatsächlich nicht stattgefunden hat, es wurde geredet, geredet, geredet, aber es hat einfach mal eine Woche gedauert, bis angefangen wurde zu sagen, okay, was ist der Islam? Wie funktioniert so ein Terror? Wer ist dieser Bin Laden? Also das waren alles nur sehr, sehr viele Mutmaßungen und dann sind natürlich irgendwie die üblichen Verdächtigen, also Dagobert Lindlau und Henry Kissinger zu Wort gekommen und dass da gefilterte Informationen kommen, das wissen wir ja spätestens seit Vietnam schon. Wen haben wir denn als nächstes? Thomas! Tja, Thomas? Thomas? Was ist denn Thomas? Ja gut, dann versuchen wir es mal mit Florian. Hallo Florian.
Ja, also zum Thema ungefilterter Information würde ich gerne was sagen. Und zwar alle, die sich mal mit dem Thema irgendwie Journalismus, Informationen beschäftigt haben und ihre, ja so, ja, weltweite Infos aus dem Radio, Fernsehen oder sonst woher genießen, die sollten doch schon längst viel früher mal irgendwann drüber nachgedacht haben, inwiefern da irgendwas überhaupt ungefiltert durchkommt, oder? Also es ist doch total unwahrscheinlich. Ich meine, die Infos, die wir dargestellt kriegen, aus Afghanistan, also überhaupt Infos. Jede Info, die du nicht selber gesehen, gehört oder geführt hast, ist sowieso eine ungefilterte.
Und die ist sogar auch noch gefiltert, weil du sie gesehen hast.
Ja genau, die ist dann für mich persönlich gefiltert, so lange wie ich sie nicht weitergebe. Also was ich irgendwie auf den Punkt bringen wollte, ich find's ein bisschen affig, wenn sich lauter Leute, die sich jeden Tag irgendwie in einem dekadenten Materialismus tummeln und sich dann aufregen über irgendwelche gefilterten Infos, über Sachen, die sie vorher nie interessiert haben, bevor nicht irgendwelche Jumbo in irgendwelche Häuser geknallt sind. Und dann sitzen die zu Hause, also ihr merkt vielleicht, das regt mich gerade ein bisschen ziemlich auf.
Das ist vielleicht wirklich die Frage, wollen die Leute das überhaupt wissen?
Ja, die Leute wollen's wissen, wollen's wissen, wenn's aktuell wird, wenn's coole Pics dazu im Fernsehen und im Internet gibt und vorher interessiert sie gar nicht. Zum Beispiel, was ihr vorhin auch in den Räumen gestellt habt. Muss ich auch sagen, ihr seid da ziemlich cool und so weiter. Aber das war auch irgendwie ein bisschen schwach. Zum Beispiel von wegen Thema sich über den Islam informieren. Oder sich darüber aufregen, dass jetzt erst über den Islam informiert wird. Ich mein, also das ist schon die Fragestellung, muss man sich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, dass über den Islam informiert wird. Ich lebe in Berlin, zum Beispiel. Ja, schon immer, seitdem ich denken und atmen kann. Ich lebe hier seitdem, ich hier lebe mit, weiß ich wie vielen Muslimen zusammen aus aller Herren Länder. Ich hab mich schon früher dafür interessiert, bevor irgendwelche Hochhäuser zusammengefallen sind. Und ich hab nicht drauf gewartet, dass mir irgendeiner die Info mit der E-Mail schickt, mir ein Band schickt oder ein Video oder so. Oder mir das im Radio sei ich verwirrt. Ich mein, cool, das ist auf jeden Fall nett und so. Aber wenn ich was wissen will, dann geh ich los und informiere mich.
Ja, aber du musst ja, du hast ja wahrscheinlich auch eine Motivation gehabt, dich über den Islam zu informieren.
Naja, für mich ist eine Motivation, wenn ich mit Muslimen zusammenarbeite, wenn Muslime meine Nachbarn sind und wenn ich bei Muslimen einkaufe.
Ja, aber es gibt mindestens 17 Millionen Deutsche, deren Nachbarn sind keine Muslime und entsprechend gehen sie auch mit Ausländern um.
Echt, wo wohnen die in Schweden und wo sie sonst verbrannt werden oder was?
Beispielsweise. Also ich meine, da ist dann natürlich auch die Frage, wie kriegen die Leute die Information? Ich meine, wenn der Islam noch nicht mal dein Nachbar ist, also wenn du nicht neben den Muslimen wohnst, dann hast du doch überhaupt keine Veranlassung, dich darum zu kümmern.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, also vielleicht habe ich da so ein arrogantes Großstädtertum drauf oder so, aber ich weiß nicht, wo sind denn Muslime nicht meine Nachbarn? Ich meine, unsere Bundesregierung hat seit Jahren, egal wer welche Partei an der Macht war, hat seit Jahren voll drauf gehabt, die Leute, also zum Beispiel gerade Asylsuchende, Bewerber aus, die können ja sonst woher kommen, das müssen gar keine Muslime sein, aber es waren auch viele Muslime dabei. Wir haben unsere Regierungen immer gut drauf gehabt, die Leute in irgendwelche Gegenden zu stecken, wo die Leute sich mit so jemanden nicht ausgekannt haben und sie haben sie da getoisiert. Und dann, naja, ich weiß nicht, sofort hatten wir auch keinen Austausch.
Ja gut, vielleicht kann ich ja den Faden wieder aufnehmen. Falls sich jetzt jemand von der Hörerschaft da noch nicht hinreichend informiert fühlt, was den Islam betrifft, da kann ich auch Abhilfe schaffen. Ich habe auf contramotion.com/sourcesorgislam ein paar Links, zum Beispiel www.convertstoislam.org, da gibt es das Ganze quasi als Anleitung. Also wie man zum Islam… Das ist eine hübsche Seite.
Das geht schon ein bisschen weit, aber ich meine, das ist nicht der Punkt. Was du gerade gesagt hast, ist der Punkt. Wer sich nicht genug informiert fühlt. Also ich persönlich für mich, also ich bin schon manchmal phlegmatisch, aber… Schön. Ja, das ist schön, wenn jemand selbst… Die Formulierung, wer sich nicht informiert genug fühlt, das sagt schon so viel aus. Wenn ich was wissen will, dann geh ich los und hol mir das Wissen.
Was weißt du übers Rheinland? Was weißt du übers Rheinland und was weißt du über Rheinländer?
Soll ich dir was sagen zum Rheinland? Ausländer rein, Rheinländer raus.
Genau. So, und jetzt wohnst du irgendwo in einem der sogenannten 5 neuen Bundesländer. Dein Nachbar ist kein Rheinländer, also beschäftigst du dich nicht mit dem Rheinland. Jetzt wohnst du in einem der sogenannten 5 neuen Bundesländer mit einem Ausländeranteil, der irgendwo weit unter 5% liegt. Hallo, exemplarisch. Wo ein Ausländeranteil von unter 5% ist. Warum sollte sich jemand von diesen Leuten mit Ausländern und deren Mentalität und auch Religion beschäftigen?
Also mich würde es zum Beispiel wundern, wenn die Leute, mit denen ich zur Grundschule gegangen bin, anfangen, irgendwelche Leute aus anderen Ländern anzuzünden.
Ja, natürlich. Das machen nur Leute, die mit Leuten aus anderen Ländern bisher keinen großartigen Kontakt hatten und anfällig für dumpf deutsches Gedanken gut sind.
Ist das ein Grund? Sag mir nicht, dass das ein Grund ist.
Das ist kein Grund.
Na ja, es ist zumindest keine Rechtfertigung. Ein Grund wahrscheinlich schon.
Aber nicht mal das. Also ich bin schon echt verständnisvoll. Aber nicht mal das.
Falls jetzt gerade der Eindruck entstanden ist, ich würde irgendwie einen von diesen schwachsinnigen Rechten verstehen, das tue ich nicht. Also ich bringe denen kein Verständnis entgegen.
Nein, das wäre auch das letzte, was ich dir unterstellen würde. Aber die würden euch jetzt das erste Blatt machen.
Florian, du alter Fleckmatiker, ich wünsche dir noch einen schönen Abend.
Ja, ihr auch, ihr Fleckmaten.
Tschüss.
Fleck-Maten ist auch sehr schön. Ihr Fleck-Maten. Holger!
Ja, hallo.
Alte Fleck-Mate. Schöner Name. Kommen wir mal zur Sache.
Also erstmal cool, dass Bommi Baumann bei euch im Studio ist. Herzliche Grüße, finde ich irgendwie sehr nett. Zum anderen muss ich sagen, der Typ, der gerade dran war, der spricht mir ziemlich aus der Seele. Also ich finde auch, dass man insgesamt eine sehr große Erwartungshaltung an den Tag legt, was so das Informiert-Werden betrifft. Also wenn irgendwas passiert, dann will man sofort Bilder davon sehen und sofort wissen, was überall passiert. Und also dieses vielfache Aufregen, dass man da auf Afghanistan immer nur diese viel zitierten grün verpixelten Bilder sieht. Ich meine, was erwartet man denn da? Es kriegt, es ist mitten in der Nacht. Also wer soll denn? Ja, ich weiß nicht. Also ich finde irgendwie, man kann ja auch nicht immer alles wissen irgendwie. Also es geht doch auch einfach gar nicht. Gleichwohl fühle ich mich auch über viele Sachen nicht richtig informiert. Also das ist davon mal abgesehen. Und ich denke, dass da auch viel verschwiegen wird. Aber ich finde halt auch, dass es schon ein bisschen gefährlich ist, dass man sich über vieles so ausregt. Und was Florian, ich glaube, gerade gesagt hat, das stimmt doch einfach. Man kann sich über vieles informieren. Es gibt verschiedene Medien aller Arten. Und dieser Dokumentarfilm, über den ihr vorhin geredet habt, der war doch echt ein gutes Beispiel. Ich meine, das ist doch Wahnsinn, dass man hier einfach den Fernseher einschalten kann und aus einem Land, wo Kameras und alles verboten sind, sich in Richtung angucken kann. Also das hat ja schon fast wieder was Perverses irgendwie. Aber ich finde, dass man da, ja, man ist da sehr schnell dabei zu sagen, da wird man falsch informiert und man erfährt nicht, was wirklich los ist. Also ich finde, man kann sich schon informieren.
Kann man sich auch so weit informieren in Deutschland, dass man guten Gewissens in den Krieg ziehen kann, wie es die Regierung erwartet für den Fall, dass wir in den Krieg ziehen?
Die verstehe ich nicht so richtig, die Frage.
Das Problem, was ich dieser Tage sehe, ist, dass unsere Regierung in unserem Namen, also bereit ist, in unserem Namen Krieg zu führen, ohne uns ausreichende Informationen darüber zu liefern, was denn diesen Krieg rechtfertigt.
Und gegen wen geführt ist.
Gut, davon mal ganz abgesagt.
Wir hören uns mal weiter, zurzeit ist eine NATO-Aktion in Mazedonien am Start, unter Führung der BRD, da hört man nichts von. Das sind irgendwie ein paar tausend Soldaten da unten, soweit ich das beheiße.
Das ist aber auch nicht spektakulär genug derzeit für die Medien.
Vielleicht ja doch.
Ja, das ist nochmal eine andere Sache. Also ich lasse mir sowieso nicht in meinem Namen für einen Politiker vorschreiben, was er tut oder so.
Na, das tust du, indem du den Pass der Bundesrepublik Deutschland besitzt.
Ja, aber da kann ich, was soll ich machen? Soll ich den abgeben und startenlos werden?
Coole Idee.
Ja, aber das finde ich Blödsinn. Also es ist die gleiche Argumentation, mit der man sagt, jeder, der da im World Trade Center war, ist irgendwo ja doch auch schuldig, weil er ja Amerikaner ist und auch am Kapitalismus teilnimmt und so ein Scheiß. Also das finde ich irgendwie, also ja, ne, weiß ich nicht. Das ist so eine komische Grundhaltung, mit der ich nicht so viel anfangen kann.
Ja, aber wenn jetzt in deinem Namen Krieg geführt wird, was es ja wird, wenn die Bundesrepublik Deutschland in den Krieg zieht, dann tut sie das auch in deinem Namen. Wenn darauf jetzt jemand antwortet, nämlich auch mit Krieg, dann wird denen auch nicht interessieren, ob du da jetzt irgendwie mit Schuld warst oder ob du da nicht mit Schuld warst. Also ist es doch zumindest die Pflicht der Bundesregierung, dich so weit ausreichend zu informieren, dass du für dich selbst erwähnen kannst, ob du nicht vielleicht doch die Staatsbürgerschaft zurückgibst?
Ja, das stimmt sicherlich, klar. Aber das ist, ich finde, das sind nochmal zwei verschiedene Sachen, ob man ausreichend informiert wird. Ich finde es natürlich auch den Wahnsinn, Afghanistan zu bombardieren, wo klar ist, dass da unschuldige Menschen bei sterben und so. Aber das ist nochmal was, das hat für mich jetzt nichts mit dieser mangelnden Information zu tun. Auch wenn man mir jetzt einwandfrei nachweisen würde, dass Bin Laden dahinter steckt, was ich im Übrigen aber auch glaube, hat es immer noch nichts damit zu tun, dass es gerecht ist, einen Krieg zu führen.
Ich rede auch nicht von einem gerechten Krieg. Ich wollte nur da einhaken, wo du sagtest, du bist deines Erachtens ausreichend informiert, beziehungsweise hast die Möglichkeit, dich ausreichend zu informieren. Das bestreite ich.
Ich glaube nicht, dass mich einer so gut informieren kann, dass ich am Ende für einen Krieg bin. Da muss ich nicht gut informiert sein, um zu wissen, dass Krieg letztendlich immer unschuldige Menschen trifft.
Okay, klammern wir Ethik aus. Wenn man jetzt wirklich ethische Bedenken, die man da hat, ausklammert, und die muss man haben, Bist du in der Lage, auf einer rein technischen Sicht zu sagen, okay, das ist in Ordnung, dass wir da Krieg führen, oder ist es nicht in Ordnung, dass wir da Krieg führen?
Natürlich bin ich dazu in der Lage. Ich kann noch sagen, ich finde es nicht in Ordnung, dass wir da Krieg führen.
Das ist jetzt wieder eine ethische Diskussion.
Ja, aber ich finde, das ist auch, wie gesagt, das ist für mich jetzt ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil es hat nichts mit Informationen zu tun, ob man führt oder gegen Krieg ist. Es hat schon auch damit zu tun, aber das ist jetzt in dem Fall, ja, weiß ich nicht. Da habe ich jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass ich mehr Informationen brauche, um da zu sagen, es ist gut oder es ist schlecht. Ich habe das Gefühl, es ist eher schlechtes, weil ich täglich höre, dass da Menschen sterben. Ich weiß natürlich nicht, ob nicht viel, viel mehr Menschen sterben, was ich mir auch vorstellen kann. Das ist ein Punkt, der in der Tat zu bemängeln ist. Dass ich nicht glaube, wenn eine ganze Nacht eine Stadt bombardiert wird, dass es am nächsten Tag drei Tote gegeben hat oder so. Also selbst die Zahlen von den Taliban, die erscheinen mir oft noch sehr niedrig. Und das ist natürlich was, wo ich mich natürlich schon frage. Auf der anderen Seite weiß ich natürlich auch nicht, woher ich die Erwartungshaltung nehme, dass mir jeden Morgen einer genau erzählt, was da nachts passiert ist. Also ich meine, wer bin ich denn? Weißt du, das finde ich schon irgendwie...
Du bist Teil des Souveräns, in dessen Namen eine Regierung Politik macht. Und als Teil des Souveräns hast du ein verdammtes Recht, darüber informiert zu werden, welcher Art die Politik ist, die die Regierung, die du legitimiert hast, macht.
Ja, da hast du sicherlich recht. Soweit würde ich dir schon zustimmen. Aber ich finde schon, es gibt so eine Haltung, wie der eben gesagt hat, der andere Anrufer, man kann sich über den Islam informieren, wenn es einen interessiert. Und ich finde, gerade in dem Fall wurde man sehr viel informiert. Also wenn man den Völkner auch direkt die Tage nach dem Anschlag gelesen hat, da gab es ganz viele Sachen, die gleich darauf hingewiesen haben, dass der Islam jetzt nicht mit den Terroranschlägen gleichzusetzen ist. Also teilweise ging mir das fast zu weit, das Verständnis für den Islam oder für die... Oh na ja. Nein, es ist schnell auch Begründung und Rechtfertigung gesucht worden für die Anschläge und so. Also ich finde da... Und das war wirklich auch sehr... Also ja, gab es von der einen bis zur anderen Seite eine sehr große spannende Meinung. Wie gesagt, es gibt immer Fälle, wo ich auch finde, klar, da wird man irgendwie auch im Argen gehalten und für dumm verkauft. Also ich fand das im Kosovo-Krieg zum Beispiel viel, viel schlimmer als jetzt in dem Krieg hier.
Echt, warum?
Ja, weil ich da das Gefühl hatte, dass die Presse einigermaßen gleichgeschaltet war, dass man da irgendwie ziemlich aneckte, wenn man da sagte, Moment mal, da stimmt was nicht, dann wurde man gleich so ein latenter Milošević-Sympathisant. Und in dem Fall jetzt bei dem Krieg, da finde ich, da ist es absolut legitim, dass man da auch sagt, das findet man nicht gut.
Hat er recht, im Kosovo-Krieg war es so, die Überschrift über den Kosovo-Krieg war, die Verhinderung einer humanitären Katastrophe. Und jetzt haben wir hier die Herbeiführung einer humanitären Katastrophe als Programm. Was noch viel interessanter ist an dem Begriff der humanitären Katastrophe, ist die Art und Weise, wie unser Außenminister derzeit damit umgeht. Unser Außenminister sagt nämlich mittlerweile, wir führen einen Krieg in die Taliban auch zur Verhinderung einer humanitären Katastrophe. Interessanterweise hat exakt diese humanitäre Katastrophe, die auch vor dem 11. September stattgefunden hat, keine Sau interessiert hier bei uns. Das finde ich irgendwie interessant. Also die Überschrift ist eine andere. In Kosovo wurde gesagt, das ist ein humanitärer Einsatz und wer dagegen ist, ist gegen Menschen.
Klar, die ganze Argumentation, wir haben den Kosovo-Krieg hier mit Auschwitz, Nürnberg.
In diesem Fall ist es nicht so sehr. In diesem Fall wird einfach ein Krieg gegen eine Macht geführt. Wie die Fuß, die auch sein mag. Und da darfst du dann eher dagegen sein.
Viel schockierender, finde ich, bei der Gegend.
In der Kosovo-Kriege haben die Taliban auch schon seit drei Jahren in Afghanistan gewütet. Das wusste man auch und dennoch hat es niemanden interessiert. Und da hat auch keiner gesagt, wir werden da gar nicht informiert. Sondern jetzt sagt man es halt, weil es irgendwie aktuell ist. Und ja, das finde ich schon ein bisschen bedenklich. Also gut, darauf wollte ich nochmal hinweisen, dass ich bei allem, was man vielleicht das Recht hätte, zu wissen und was einem verheimlicht wird, und ich finde auch diese Informationspolitik der Amerikaner natürlich auch eine Katastrophe zu dem Krieg. Und dennoch, finde ich, muss man schon auch mal sehen, dass es schon der Hammer ist, wenn man irgendwo hört, aha, in New York ist ein Anschlag, man weiß, man kann den Fernseher anschalten und sieht dann sofort live, was da passiert. Also das ist schon auch ein gewisser Luxus, der nicht so selbstverständlich ist, finde ich.
Ich finde, es führt vor allen Dingen zu einer Realitätsverschiebung. Also ich habe da gesessen und habe gedacht, ja, krass.
Sylvester Stallone oder was auch immer.
Weil die Bilder auch so genau so aussehen. Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass es wirklich so aussieht, wenn ein Flugzeug in den Hochplatz fliegt, dass dann so eine Explosion kommt. Man hat wirklich gar nicht vor Augen, dass der Mensch in den Flugzeug kommt.
Aber letztendlich reden wir hier. Im Moment finde ich ein bisschen leicht am Thema vorbei, außer dass man vielleicht sagen kann, diese Bin Laden-Terrorgänge oder wer das auch immer war, auf jeden Fall beherrschen diese Leute das mit der Medienmanipulation ganz genauso.
Noch besser.
Nicht ohne Amuse-Monde kann ich mir mit den Nachrichten reinziehen und da irgendwie sehen, die Amerikaner kommen zwar mit ihrer so, wir zeigen euch die einzigsten Bilder und so fort, sondern dass die da jetzt zum Beispiel diese Al-Qa'ya jetzt mehr oder weniger ein eigenes CNN aufgemacht haben und sagen, so Jungs, hier kommt jetzt irgendwie unsere Wahrheit und so fort. Also das finde ich schon irgendwie nett, aber...
Was kommt man zu Al Jazeera, diesen Sender aus Katar?
Aber ich meine, für mich ist das Ergebnis davon, das Einzelne, was ich irgendwie als Realität akzeptieren kann, ist die Gesamtheit der sozusagen virtuellen Realitäten, der Propagandaschlachten und irgendwie all das zusammen. Das ist dann irgendwie Realität sozusagen. Aber jetzt irgendwie mich auf die Suche nach einer objektiven Berichterstattung zu machen, da unternehme ich nicht mal mehr den Versuch in dem Sinne.
Na klar, die muss man sich letztendlich versuchen, aus dem was man hat zu bilden. Aber die Frage ist halt auch, was würde man jetzt erwarten? Also was wäre denn die objektive Wahrheit in dem Fall? Also was fändet ihr jetzt müsste getan werden, damit ihr euch über diesen Krieg ausreichend informiert wird? Oder wer sollte das tun, besser gesagt?
Ich würde erstmal dahinstellen, es gibt überhaupt keine objektive Wahrheit. Also du hast eigentlich deine eigene Wahrheit und das ist der Punkt irgendwie. Da brauchst du eine gewisse Kompetenz irgendwie zu bilden. Deswegen brauchst du Informationen, brauchst du Quellen.
Gut, dann nehmen wir die Informationen aus. Es gibt ja das Faktische. Es gibt ja vielleicht eine Möglichkeit zu sagen, diese zehn Leute werden jetzt jeweils separat die Leichenzellen, die in Afghanistan liegen und diese Zahlen veröffentlichen. Und möglicherweise kommen die ja auf identische Zahlen. Und dann wissen wir wenigstens wie viele Tote da wirklich sind. Da ist von auszugehen, dass wir es in zehn Jahren nicht wissen.
Klar, man kann sich jeden Morgen die Bildzeitung kaufen, dann wird man wahrscheinlich nicht besonders stark informiert sein. Man kann aber auch morgens Info-Radio hören, abends eine Sendung wie eure hören, kann dann die Zeit lesen oder die konkret oder sich dann so einen Dokumentarfilm auf Arte angucken und sich mit Leuten unterhalten. Das Problem nun, mein lieber Holger, ist, dass ein bisschen mehr und irgendwo dazwischen liegt dann so die Wahrheit, die man sich daraus bilden kann.
Das Problem nun, mein lieber Holger, ist, dass die BZ, die am meisten verkaufte Zeitung in Berlin ist und keine andere. Und da steht bestimmt keine Wahrheit drin.
Ja, das ist ein Problem seit Menschengedenken, dass die meisten Menschen das zeigen.
Ein Problem seit Menschengedenken, dass die BZ verkauft. Holger, wir müssen Nachrichten machen.
Abschließend, die Schlagzeile, zieh dich warm an, binladen, fand ich wiederum ziemlich cool. Das wäre in einer gewissen Originalität.
Darauf würde ich mich einlassen. Ich wünsche eine schöne Nacht. Thorsten, Matthias und Martin nach den Nachrichten. Und dann geht's weiter. Musik aus Indien im Chaosradio 66, ja das hier ist das Chaosradio auf Fritz in Berlin, dann 102, 6, eine nach halb eins.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Heute Nacht regnet es aber nur ein bisschen, das ganze bei 9 bis 5 Grad. Morgen regnet es möglicherweise weniger, aber möglicherweise auch nicht, denn es wird wolkenreich bei 12 bis 15 Grad. Die Meldung jetzt mit Bastian Boerner.
Bundeskanzler Schröder hat erneut eine Feuerpause in Afghanistan zur Lösung der humanitären Probleme abgelehnt. Sie würde die Auseinandersetzung nur verlängern und brächte den Menschen nicht, sagte Schröder am Abend nach einem Gespräch mit Frankreichs Staatspräsidenten Chirac und Premierminister Jospin in Paris. Die in Gang gesetzte Entwaffnung der nordirischen Untergrundorganisation IAA hat den Friedensprozess neu belebt. Die britische Region kündigte die Auflösung von vier Militärstützpunkten an. Auch die Reform der bisher protestantisch dominierten Polizei von Nordirland soll nun zügig umgesetzt werden. Das Ausmaß des Feuers im Schweizer Gottertunnel ist weiterhin unklar. Die Behörden rechnen bis zu 20 Toten. Ein direkter Zugang zum Brandherd war wegen der extremen Hitze bis zum Abend noch nicht möglich. Und nun zum Sport. In der Fußball Champions League setzen sich am Abend Borussia Dortmund gegen Dynamo Kiew mit 1 zu 0 durch. Damit kann Dortmund am kommenden Dienstag beim FC Liverpool aus eigener Kraft die nächste Runde erreichen. Ausgeschrieben ist dagegen Schalke 04, der deutsche Vizemeister unterlag bei Panathinaikos Athen mit 0 zu 2. Der deutsche Basketballmeister Albert Berlin bleibt auf internationalem Parkett sieglos am 3. Spieltag. Der EuroLeague unterlagen die Berliner bei FSC Istanbul mit 68 zu 72. Nach der dritten Niederlage in Folge sind die Chancen der Albatros auf das Erreichen der Zwischenrunde auf ein Minimum gesunken. Ich hab's extra schnell gemacht, darauf zu lachen. Der Fritzverkehr. A100-Stadtrink zwischen Dreig Tempelow und Britzer Dam bis Ende des Monats, Sperrung der linken Spuren Richtung Treptow, Kreuzberg an der Kreuzung Friedrich- und Kochstraße bis Ende des Monats, Behinderung wegen Bauarbeiten, Stadtverkehr. Potsdam-Breite Straße zwischen Schuppenhorststraße und Langer Brücke bis Mitte Dezember, Behinderung in beiden Richtungen. Das links abbiegen in die Dorfstraße ist nicht möglich.
Bastian? Das ist Maxi Jazz von Faithless. Hi, das ist Maxi Jazz von Faithless, wieder einmal.
Gott ist ein DJ.
Ich bin Fritz. Und im Radio.
Chaosradio 66, gegen Öffentlichkeit in den Zeiten der Krise.
Andy, du möchtest jetzt den Nachwuchsförderpreis für politisches Kamerad entgegen.
Wir haben ja gerade den Desinformationssprecher hier drin.
Also den von Fritz offiziell bestellten Nachrichtensprecher. Und ich finde, wir sollten uns diese erste Meldung nochmal kurz auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Bundeskanzler Schröder hat erneut eine Feuerpause in Afghanistan zur Lösung der humanitären Probleme.
Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp mal eben. Die Art und Weise, wie du vorträgst, ist wertend. Das möchte ich nicht. Ja, soll ich.
Mach mal.
Bundeskanzler Schröder hat erneut eine Feuerpause in Afghanistan zur Lösung der humanitären Probleme abgelehnt, verzeihung.
War freut.
Sie würde die Auseinandersetzung nur verlängern und brächte den Menschen nichts, sagte Schröder am Abend nach einem Gespräch mit Frankreichs Staatspräsidenten Chirac und Premierminister Jospin in Paris.
Die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, woher weiß denn Herr Schröder das?
Geheimdienstinformationen.
Moment, der Herr Chirac und der Herr Jospin haben ihm das gesagt.
Genau, die haben nämlich gesagt, pass mal auf, Schröder, wenn du nicht willst, dass wir dir in den Arsch treten, dann sagst du genau das.
Ja, das ist ja ganz toll.
Oder?
Ich meine, ihr berichtet das ja nur, aber die Frage, die man sich ja stellen könnte, sagen sie mal, lieber Herr Bundeskanzler, was reden Sie denn hier eigentlich für einen Scheiß?
Woher willst du wissen, dass das Scheiß ist?
Ja, also ich meine, eine Feuerpause heißt doch, dass man nicht schießt, ne? Und wenn da Menschen sind, die gerade versuchen, irgendwie ihr Leben zu retten, dann hilft man denen, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dadurch, dass man nicht auf sie schießt.
Ja, aber die werden doch mit so kleinen gelben Paketen, wo Kekse drin sind, beworfen. Und Hinbeermarmelade. Und da sind ja immerhin mittlerweile schon über 200.000 von diesen Paketen abgeworfen worden, und weißt du auch warum? Um die Flüchtlinge zu verarschen.
Ja, weil erstens werden die teilweise in Minengebieten abgeworfen, wo irgendwie alleine schon das Suchen nach diesen Paketen einfach mal gefährlich ist.
Weißt du, was ein Minenräumenpanzer kostet?
Ja, richtig Asche.
Und weißt du, was so ein Paket kostet?
Allerdings habe ich auch verlautbaren hören, dass die ein oder anderen Pakete da gerade öffentlich verbrannt werden, weil die Bevölkerung sich auch ein bisschen davon verarscht fühlt, mit Bomben und mit Lebensmittelpaketen beworfen zu werden. Denen würde es ja völlig reichen, wenn sie mit genau gar nichts beworfen werden würden. Und das kann ich irgendwie auf eine Art nachvollziehen.
Gut, jetzt kommt das Gegenargument. Sie würden ja auch mit gar nichts beworfen, wenn sie denn Osama bin Laden auslieferten.
Ja, da hätten sie aber gerne Beweise für, weil die halt da eine Rechtsstaatssimulation offenbar aufrechterhalten, so wie es andere Länder eben auch tun. Also wir würden ja auch, nehmen wir mal an, der Taliban kommt jetzt an und sagt, er fordert jetzt die Auslieferung von Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder, weil der offenbar, keine Ahnung, Unsinn redet. So, und dann sagen wir doch auch, also dann weisen wir uns mal nach, dass der Unsinn redet.
Richtig.
Wir liefern den Mann ja nicht einfach aus, so. Macht ja irgendwie Sinn.
Ja gut, jetzt...
Aber Sinn ist ja sowieso nicht mehr gefragt. Okay, lass uns mit dem nächsten Hörrad reden.
Genau, lass uns telefonieren, bevor wir uns hier noch weiterfetzeln und nachher unten in Empfang genommen werden von der Gedankeneußerheit. Obwohl Bommi sprengt uns den Weg frei.
Wir haben hier Puderzucker.
Wieso? Nee, wir haben nur Antragspulver.
Mir reicht Puderzucker.
Für Puderzucker musst du ein Antragsformular ausfüllen. Tut mir leid. Matthias.
Geht das auch mit Lufthansa-Schokolade?
Moment noch, Matthias, wir sind gleich fertig. Matthias, schieß los, bevor wir wieder anfangen.
Ja gut, dann werd ich gleich mal los schießen. Aber es war schon sehr schön, ihr habt ja gerade euch über diese Nachrichten mal ausgelassen und auch über die Meldung. Und ich find ja schon mal ganz schön an dieser Meldung, sie hat wenigstens mal einen Inhalt gehabt, dass sie dann inhaltlich zu kritisieren ist. Das ist natürlich der zweite große Kritikpunkt, den ich an den Medien habe. Aber es ist auch einfach so, grundsätzlich muss jemand nur wichtig genug sein. Der kann eine Scheiße labern von vorne zu hinten, was also wirklich ohne jeden Erkennbarkeit wenig ist. Aber es wird gedruckt, es wird gedruckt, es wird überall gemacht. Das nervt mich ganz, ganz, ganz groß.
Die schönste Meldung in diesem Zusammenhang finde ich immer, Person xy, also meistens Politiker xy, bekräftigt irgendetwas. Also der wird nicht müde zu sagen, dass Schwarz schwarz ist und jeder druckt es ab. Und zwar täglich, das finde ich immer sehr süß.
Ja, und halt wirklich diese ganzen Inhaltswehren floskeln. Ja, und da denke ich mir, da muss einfach mal auch ein Bewusstsein bei den Journalisten für geschaffen werden. Also ich selber möchte mich mal so als angehenden Journalisten bezeichnen.
Wie äußert sich das?
Na ja, also ich...
Hast du schon Schuldgefühle?
Na das noch nicht so ganz, weil ich versuche mir dessen bewusst zu sein und ich versuche das bei den Sachen, die ich mache, auch umzusetzen.
Moment, ich möchte einfach... Was heißt angehender Journalist? Studierst du irgendwas? Bist du auf einer Journalistenschule?
Nein, also ich studiere irgendwas, ja ich studiere Jura, aber ich habe halt mal vor einem Jahr bei der Tatzenpraktikum gemacht und schreibe hin und wieder mal für die. Aber selbst bei so einem kritischen, wirklich vom Gedanken her kritischen Medium wie der Tatz ist es halt so, ich habe halt Sachen zurückgekriegt, die haben mir gesagt, ja das ist halt inhaltlich sehr klasse, was du da schreibst, aber such doch mal jemanden, der nicht nur gute Sachen sagt, sondern der irgendwie auch wichtig ist. Und das ist auch einfach so ein Kriterium, was mich halt ganz extrem stört. Also warum kann nicht das Argument fehlen?
Weil Kleider Leute machen.
Ja, also das ist so eine Sache, die finde ich sehr unschön. Also insofern hoffe ich auch darauf, dass ein meines Erachtens ganz interessantes Projekt von seiner Konzeption her, NGO Online, eine Internet-Tageszeitung, die halt eben auch die NGOs mal zu Worte kommen lassen will.
NGOs für alle, die es nicht wissen, Non-Governmental Organizations, also Nicht-Regierungsorganisationen.
Ganz kurz, ist das NGO Online Org oder was ist das?
Die Ehe, ja, ich glaube die Org gibt es auch oder so. Also von der Konzeption her, ich denke in der Umsetzung gibt es da noch ganz massive Schwächen, was vermutlich auch schlicht auf den finanziellen Hintergrund zurückzuführen ist.
Aber auch hier, also NGOs sind ja in der Zwischenzeit wirklich nicht unbedingt so die unwichtigen, oder?
Dieses Projekt zumindest, dass es da ein Problem gibt, aber wie dem auch sei, also auf jeden Fall finde ich das halt mal einfach den Gedanken dahinter, nicht die Person in den Vordergrund zu stellen, sondern den Inhalt und solange irgendjemand Inhalte liefert, die nun gut, also es darf natürlich kein braunes Gesappel sein, also sowas kommt natürlich nicht rein, aber einfach zu sagen, wir liefern die Meinung, wir liefern die Argumente vor allem und ihr müsst euch dann als Leser selber Gedanken darüber machen. Es geht auch in die Richtung, was jemand von euch schon gesagt hatte, eine objektive Wahrheit gibt es nicht, sondern die Wahrheit muss sich aus der Gesamtmenge der Informationen zusammenstellen und dafür ist es halt natürlich erstmal erforderlich, dass überhaupt eine Gesamtmenge der Informationen vorhanden ist und nicht nur einseitig die Wirtschaftsbosse sich einkaufen und die Mächtigen sich einkaufen in die Medien. Das wollte ich nochmal gesagt haben, finde ich halt wirklich eine ganz wichtige Sache. Ich finde diese natürlich auch Indymedia und Co. extrem wichtig. Bloß ich denke, es ist halt vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, wenn noch sowas auch da ist wie NGO Online, wo halt gesagt wird, wir versuchen das mal auch noch redaktionär ein bisschen aufzuarbeiten. Was halt, wenn ich mir Indymedia angucke, gut, ich hatte jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht mehr so richtig die Zeit, mich insgesamt überhaupt vernünftig zu informieren. Was da dann doch noch so war, dass es halt wirklich sehr unterschiedlich auch vom Niveau her ist, sehr unterschiedlich von Stil her ist und ja halt vieles wirklich in mehreren Diskussionsbeiträgen her sind.
Durchaus, aber das ist natürlich irgendwie der Punkt. Du sagst das ja auch vorhin irgendwie, das ist wichtige Menschen machen Nachrichten, bei Indymedia machen es halt unwichtige Menschen. Also irgendwie ist das der entscheidende Punkt. Und die unwichtigen Menschen haben ja auch eine Meinung, die dürfen ja auch was sagen, oder?
Ja, das ist natürlich, das ist auch genau die, also ich denke ja auch unwichtige Menschen, in Anführungszeichen sind wichtig, ihre Meinung zu sagen. Also ich denke, es ist halt noch so eine weitere Ergänzung nochmal. Und das auf dieser redaktionellen Ebene eben mehr zu machen.
Ja.
Das war's?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich meine vielleicht doch ganz kurz zu den Nachrichten. Es ist so, ich hab mal mitgezählt, es waren drei richtige Meldungen. Dann zwei Sportmeldungen, die viel länger waren als diese nun wahrlich wichtige Meldung. Und dann noch mal Verkehr in Anführungszeichen, aber Verkehr ausschließlich beschränkt auf den motorisierten Individualverkehr. Den motorisierten Individualverkehr mit solchen Verkehrsmeldungen abzuspeisen, bringt sowieso nichts. Da müsstest du eine Stunde machen und hättest nicht alle Sachen durch. Wo das einen Sinn hätte, den öffentlichen Personennahverkehr, der wird unterschlagen. Muss das sein?
Matthias, erstens, holst du... Ich hole sie jetzt sehr weit aus. Es ist offensichtlich so, denn ansonsten würden solche Sachen, also nicht in allen Medien und sämtlichen Gesprächen, die so tagtäglich stattfinden, Einfluss nehmen. Sport scheint etwas zu sein, was die Leute stärker interessiert, als beispielsweise Außen- oder Innenpolitik. Das ist eine Erfahrung, die ich gemacht habe und immer wieder mache, dass Leute sagen, ne, interessiert mich nicht, wir hatten härter gespielt. Das zum einen. Zum anderen, BVG-Fahrpreiserhöhungen führen zwar zu so ein bisschen Unbild bei den Leuten und ein bisschen Gemurre, aber wenn du den Spritpreisumgroschen erhöhst, dann gehen 200.000 Menschen auf die Straße und demonstrieren.
Gut, ich meine, bloß die Frage ist, was ist die Aufgabe des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks? Ist es die Grundinformation, wie es eigentlich nach seiner Konzeption vorgesehen ist, oder ist es die Mainstream-Information, die halt genauso durchkommerzialisiert ist, wie bei allen anderen? Das ist so die Frage. Also das ist meines Erachtens eine ziemlich gefährliche Entwicklung, die ich auch innerhalb der – ich bin von Anfang an als Fritz-Hörer mit dabei, und Fritz hat früher ein deutlich anderes Programm auch einfach inhaltlich von der Menge der politischen Beiträge, von der Qualität her, von dem Fortkommenlacken von allen möglichen Akteuren gemacht, als das in letzter Zeit ist. Also ich meine, da war früher jeden Abend ein politisches Thema. Wenn ich jetzt überlege, so ein politisches Thema ist doch eher die Ausnahme geworden.
Gut, das ist aber nicht das Problem von Fritz, sondern das ist das Problem derer, die diese Sendungen am Abend machen. Weil die Themen, die hier stattfinden, die suchen wir uns in der Tat weitestgehend selbst aus. Und wir bekommen da auch keine Einschränkungen. Darüber hinaus ist es eben so, dass Radio, also auch öffentlich-rechtliches Radio, zumindest öffentlich-rechtliches Jungradio, auch ein Massenmedium ist und seine Legitimation natürlich über eine Akzeptanz durch die Massen erreicht.
Die Frage ist ja, ob die Akzeptanz dann vielleicht auch, also ob das jetzt wirklich entscheidend ist, ne? Also wofür die Akzeptanz?
Es ist zumindest für den Chef einer Anstalt ist es entscheidend. Für den zählt, wie viele Leute haben es gehört. Erstens, wie viele Leute haben es gehört und zweitens, wie viele Leute in welchem Alter haben es vor allen Dingen gehört. Und wenn wir sagen, Fritz ist ein öffentlich-rechtliches Jugendradio, damit definierst du natürlich, wie soll ich sagen, so eine Zielgruppe. Ja, aber Entschuldigung, Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder ist auch ein demokratisch gewählter... Lass mich doch mal kurz ausreden. Damit definierst du eine Zielgruppe. Wenn du sagst, wir senden jetzt für 14- bis 29-Jährige oder 14- bis 25-Jährige, dann musst du natürlich hingehen und am Jahresende, bzw. wenn diese Umfragen gelaufen sind, vorweisen können, dass du eine definierte Anzahl an Hörern in dieser Zielgruppe hattest. Ansonsten fehlt dir die Legitimation.
Gut, also erstmal ist die Frage grundsätzlich halt, was sind die Aufgaben des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks. Da ist halt, du sagst natürlich, ich verstehe, dass der Chef sagt, ich will möglichst viele Hörer, weil einfach die Masse zählt, aber dann muss er sich halt fragen, hält er sich an die Vorgaben dessen, was die Konzeption des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks ist, eben auch andere Sachen durchzuliefern. Und abgesehen davon denke ich, dass es durchaus möglich ist, auch die heutige verdorbene Jugend, die sich für nichts mehr interessiert, als das neueste Handy, auch wirklich für politische Themen zu interessieren. Du musst sie halt bloß entsprechend daran führen. Und ich glaube, da hat sich Fritz mehr Mühe gegeben, von da aus zu drücken.
Es ist nicht so einfach, ich könnte dir das jetzt erläutern, das würde die letzten 11, ne, bzw. Es ist nicht so. Nimm das jetzt einfach mal als journalistisch wertvolle Information hin. Sicherlich ist es richtig, also ein kurzes Plädoyer dagegen oder dafür. Es ist sicherlich richtig, dass du auch, wenn du ein hoch anspruchsvolles, hoch politisiertes Programm veranstaltest, du früher oder später, sagen wir mal 100.000 Hörer, wenn wir das als Größe annehmen, 100.000 Hörer damit erreichst, die das auch gerne hören. Das ist sicherlich richtig. Du brauchst aber einen langen Atem. Du brauchst einfach einen sehr, sehr langen Atem. Und ich glaube, dass dieser lange Atem den Menschen einfach fehlt.
Welchen Menschen jetzt denn den Ratelmenschen?
Den Verantwortlichen, die sich dann wiederum vor irgendwelchen weiter vorgesetzten oder irgendwelchen Gebührenzahlern zu rechtfertigen haben. Wenn du jetzt hinlegst und machst ein hochpolitisches Programm, kriegst du damit, garantiere ich dir für, dann wirst du die ersten zwei Jahre nicht mehr als 30.000 Hörer damit erreichen, messbar erreichen. Wobei wir uns jetzt auch noch darüber unterhalten können, ob diese Umfragen stimmen oder nicht. Also Quotenermittlung ist ja auch immer so eine vage Geschichte. Die funktioniert, weil alle dran glauben, also glauben wir daran. Machst du jetzt ein hochpolitisches Programm, ein hochpolitisches, wortlastiges Programm, dann erreichst du mit Sicherheit die ersten ein, zwei Jahre 30.000 Leute und nicht mehr. Und damit nimmst du dir selbst die Legitimation. Also versuchst du doch, möglichst in einer breiten Masse, möglichst das, was du Mainstream nennst, ein Mainstream zu machen und zu versuchen, innerhalb dieses Mainstreams den ein oder anderen Anstoß zu liefern.
Gut, und ich wünsche mir mehr Anstöße.
Da musst du länger hören. Matthias, danke für deinen Anruf. Andy, was wolltest du sagen?
Du redest da mit einer Selbstverständlichkeit von, na ja, die Sender werden eben über die Quoten gemacht. Ich meine, so funktioniert natürlich Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie und so weiter und fort, das ist mir alles bekannt. Bloß mal andersherum, ich meine, Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder, der ist auch ein demokratisch gewählter, irgendwie, was ist noch? Gleich ist er noch eine Bundeskanzler. Und trotzdem redet er ja, Entschuldigung, in diesem Moment hier gerade, mal hat er einen Scheiß geredet, dass sich eigentlich die Balken, und dass man seinen Satz eigentlich nur untersuchen muss und dann stellt man fest, sachlich kann da irgendetwas nicht richtig sein. Wie kann er etwas sagen, wo er mit keinem einzigen Afghanen geredet hat, sondern mit dem Staatspräsident von Frankreich? Wie kann er dann behaupten, dass Weiterbomben den Menschen hilft? Also, ist ja einfach mal so eine sachliche Sache. Und wie gesagt, den interessiert das ja auch nicht, sondern der macht das einfach. Und ich glaube, dass wenn du weiterhin sagst, ja, über Hertha, über den Sportteil dieser Nachrichten kriegst du eben den Mehrheit der Bevölkerung, der Berliner Bevölkerung oder die Jugend oder eure Zielgruppe dazu, diesen Sender zu hören. Woran liegt denn das? Das liegt auch daran, dass eben diese Sportthemen auch in anderen Medien so gepusht werden. Das sind auch kommerzielle Interessen dahinter. Sport ist ja kein Selbstzweck.
Das ist vor allen Dingen die Frage nach dem Huhn oder dem Ei. Das ist richtig.
Ja, und insofern also so ein bisschen, glaube ich, kann man sich da schon auch mit anderen...
Was sagst du den Leuten, die ausschließlich Sport interessiert und diese Meldung vom Bundeskanzler Schröder nicht interessiert beziehungsweise die es fürchterlich ärgert, dass die Schröder-Meldung an erster Stelle in den Nachrichten steht?
Solche Leute gibt es.
Das ist eine Realitätsverschiebung vielleicht.
Ja, ich glaube, dass sie wirklich ein bisschen...
Das finde ich vermessen.
Das finde ich vermessen, aber böse.
Also wo gerade im Namen unter anderem, sozusagen der deutschen Regierung hier irgendwie, eine Bevölkerung oder zumindest ein paar Millionen Leute umgebracht werden, sich dann mehr für den Sportteil innerhalb unseres Landes interessieren, das finde ich irgendwie krank. Ja, das findest du krank.
Aber ich meine, wer oder was legitimiert dich, das krank zu finden?
Naja, wir leben ja in einer Demokratie. Da darf ich doch finden, was ich will.
Und so gesehen ist es dann doch schon ganz in Ordnung?
Die dürfen ja auch ihren Sport wichtiger finden. Das ist ja jedem freigestellt, ich will auch niemanden dazu zwingen. Bloß meine Prioritäten sind andere. Und die Frage ist ja immer, was sind deine Prioritäten, was sind unsere Prioritäten? Ich meine, das Schöne am Internet ist ja, dass sich jeder seine Realität sozusagen selbst zusammenstellen kann. Du bist ja gar nicht mehr darauf angewiesen im Internet noch, den Herrn Schröder das Afghanistan-Dilemma oder irgendetwas wahrzunehmen, sondern du kannst ja rein auf keine Ahnung, www.sportbild.de gehen oder was auch immer, und kannst dir deine Realität rein aus härter Fußball ergibt.
Das ist etwas, was auch sehr viele Menschen tun.
Ob du dann allerdings weit kommst, das ist eine andere Frage.
Du verlierst dich halt in deinem Sportteil. Das muss ja nicht Sport sein, das kann ja auch Modellschiffbau sein oder so.
Ja sicher, das kann man natürlich immer werten, aber es gibt diese Menschen, es gibt sehr viele Menschen, die die Sportbild ansurfen.
Ich meine, schlimmer geht immer, will ich ja gar nicht abstreiten.
Richtigst du bitte ins Mikrofon?
Schlimmer geht immer, will ich auch gar nicht abstreiten. Die Frage ist ja nur, wenn man jetzt tatsächlich den Anspruch hat, sich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr zu informieren, was auf dem Planeten passiert und wie die eine Hörerin, die wir jetzt da hatten, dann eben aus irgendwelchen technischen Gründen zum Beispiel auf so ein Medium wie Radio sozusagen angewiesen ist, weil eben Internet nicht überall verfügbar, Auto fahren, keine Ahnung, normale Arbeit nachgehen usw. Das ist natürlich dann traurig, wenn man dann tatsächlich nur die Auswahl hat zwischen den Sendern, die einen 7-minütigen Nachrichtenanteil mit einem 3-minütigen Sportteil haben und welchen, die einen 5-minütigen Nachrichtenanteil mit einem 4-minütigen Sportteil haben.
Weil dich Sport nicht interessiert, ja. Mich interessiert das auch nicht, aber ich nehme es eben hin, weil ich weiß, dass es Menschen gibt, die es interessieren. Bevor wir uns jetzt verzetteln, wir haben nur noch 4 Minuten und Martin, hallo Martin. Hallöchen. Du hast das letzte Wort, also mach ein schönes, ein wichtiges.
Was hältst du von Sport?
Ich hab nur ein kleiner Gedanke, der mir irgendwie so kam, weil Sport ist ja so eine Art Wettkampf. Weil ja, die betonen nicht unbedingt auf Kampf liegen sollen. Es ist ja irgendwie, entweder zwei Leute oder zwei Mannschaften treten gegeneinander an. Und irgendwie zeigt man ja eine Art gewaltfreie irgendwas Lösung. Es ist ja eine Art, ja, weiß nicht, ob ihr mich versteht.
Ja, wobei die Frage noch ist, ob Sport gewaltfrei ist.
Nee, das meine ich ja, aber ich mach was in Fußball. Oder was, wo ich Tennis. Und das ist vielleicht so eine Art, Sport ist ja irgendwas, was Leute beschäftigen soll, was ihnen irgendwie, was ihnen die Hand geben soll, woran sie sich halten können. Das eben...
Wir können auch ketzerisch sein, was sie ablenken soll.
Ja, na okay, vielleicht haben wir nicht unbedingt gemerkt, irgendwie in letzter Zeit, wie doch sehr der Sport dann kommentialisiert wurde. Das ist dann vielleicht das weitere Problem, was dann eben diese vier Minuten Sport in fünf Minuten Nachrichten ausmacht oder so. Was ich eigentlich sagen wollte...
Genau, das lese ich gerade hier und da wollte ich drauf kommen.
Spezielle Informationen und so. Was mir aufgefallen ist, also wurde sicherlich auch schon genannt öfter mal, die Sache, wie informiert wird. Zum Beispiel, Phoenix habe ich zwar immer gerne geguckt. Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen enttäuscht gewesen, zum Beispiel, wenn so irgendwelche Statements von Britikern kamen, wie George Bush oder eben von Tony Blair und sowas. Oder auch als dieses Video von Bin Laden gezeigt wurde. Und die waren ja alle in Englisch, also ob nun Bush, Blair oder Bin Laden. Und bei Bin Laden hat sich auffälligerweise irgendwie der Synchronisator, der Übersetzer, irgendwie ziemlich schwer getan, das zu übersetzen, was Bin Laden in dem Video gesagt hat.
Ja, stimmt.
Und so war das mir dann auch aufgefallen. Hat er so schlecht Englisch gesprochen, konnte er das nicht zusammenfassen in ordentliche Sätze, hat er eine schlechte Grammatik oder wollte man das nicht übersetzen?
Wir werden es nie erfahren.
Das ist eben das Problem, genau. Und ich denke, sowas ist vielleicht einfach mal wichtig zu merken und auch zu erkennen, dass Leute sowas auch sehen. Oder auch, was auch genannt wurde, dass Statements von Politikern, von wichtigen Leuten in Gänsefüßen irgendwie höher gesetzt werden als die, oder auch einfach nur als wahr hingestellt werden, im Gegensatz zu den von einfachen Leuten, von der Bevölkerung. Wenn man zum Beispiel an diese Demonstration gegen den Krieg, dann wurde oft behauptet, die hätten keine Alternative. Aber was ist denn bitte schön, das war es jetzt, wenn...
Das ist die Kapitulation des gesunden Menschenverstandes.
Das ist also die Sache, die man da rangeht. Das ist nicht wirklich das Problem.
Das würde eine breit gefächerte Medienkompetenz bedingen. Ich denke mal, in einem Land, in dem sich Zeitungen wie die Bild-Zeitung oder die BZ so großartig verkaufen, ist es mit der Medienkompetenz doch eher essig.
Ja, okay, das muss man leider nicht mehr aufsehen.
Vielleicht geht es auch darum, die Medienkompetenz herzustellen.
Das kann man versuchen, ja, sicher.
Aber ich weigere mich aber ein bisschen, die Leute einfach nur für blöd zu erklären, bloß weil sie die BZ lesen. Ich meine, auf eine Art und Weise ist das ein Comic. Und Comic hat etwas mit Vereinfachung zu tun und mit übertriebener Darstellung. Ich meine, Leute, die das bewerten können, werden auch nicht doof dadurch, dass sie sich nachrichten.
Leute, die es bewerten können, werden dadurch agitiert.
Ja, gut, aber trink doch mal einen ganzen Tag Bier und Lies BZ.
Martin, leider muss ich Schluss machen. Sag mal was, sag einen letzten Satz.
Ich habe gerade überlegt, was ich sagen wollte, aber ich komme jetzt nicht drauf. Was ich vielleicht noch ein letztes Wort, was auch gesagt wurde, diese einfachen Fragen, die nicht genau definiert werden konnten, die einfachen Fragen sind, glaube ich, das, wenn man das als Regime oder eben Aktionskritisch bezeichnen könnte, sprich, wenn man eben nach dem Grund dieser Attentäter fragt, wenn man nach dem Grund fragt, wieso Bin Laden nicht ausgeliefert wird, wenn man nach der Begründung oder wenn man infrage stellt, dass es richtig ist, weiter zu bomben oder sowas. Das ist, glaube ich, ein großes Problem. Das wird eben ziemlich schnell abgetan, als das ist falsch, dass eben nur diese Meinung, die uns vorgegeben wird von den Politikern, als die richtige angesehen wird.
Danke, Martin. Das war Chaosradio 66. Mir gibt es eigentlich ab jetzt, aber wir haben zwei Minuten überzogen, Verzeihung, den Nightfly mit Martin Petersdorf. Chaosradio 67 am letzten Mittwoch im November. Das ist der 28.11. bedanke mich bei Jan, bei Thorsten, bei Bommi und bei Andi. Mein Name ist Holger Klein. Gute Nacht. Danke fürs Zuhören und danke fürs Anrufen. Sagt noch mal alles schön Tschüss. Ein Gemeinschaftsprogramm von ORB und SFB. Produziert in Babelsberg.